Want me to introduce you,
ladies and gentlemen,
the great Everlast.
Hmm.
Okay.
Yes
ma'am.
Got to close back to
stone
black.
Black Cow.
The egg coffee.
Oh,
is
she?
Oh,
she's
jazz lag.
Joan.
Jess lack and chunky.
We'll see what bill was the south around here.
Spanish.
Oh,
grass.
Some remedial saddle fathers.
And she says,
she says
she smell flowers.
Slack.
Kismet.
Slowly,
softly
flow.
Since Shit backed though,
by offering
and the stone goes so much
coffee.
No,
didn't,
no
copy
lag.
Gotcha.
We're full of that
user.
That's how it started.
Can you hear me?
Yeah.
Okay.
Can you hear me?
Yeah.
Just everything's a little off cause we're adjusted for music.
Just want to make sure everything's cool.
Notice we didn't know commercials.
Fuck it.
What kind of shirt are you wearing today?
Joe is on a chart as podcast sponsored by on a.com.
Go to [inaudible] dot com get yourself an orangutan.
Kettlebell does the new ones and they,
uh,
there's $5 for each one of them goes to a foundation to,
to help save orangutans.
Apparently a rank tanks are in trouble.
So,
uh,
we decided that since we're buying these a,
or selling these up,
a primal bells there based on primates,
we'll do some other ones.
I don't want to tell you what the other things are,
but they're not real life animals.
But the ones that we're doing right now are all chimps,
gorillas and orangutans.
Orangutans are in trouble.
And so,
uh,
I guess they are.
I mean,
that's supposedly they're endangered.
Oh,
I thought you meant the kettle bell is in trouble.
No,
no,
no.
They're endangered.
I mean,
we still have the 1.5 pooed thing on it and I need to change that after we
talked about it yesterday.
I'm going to call,
I'll worry about that shit today.
It should say at least under it,
it should say a 35 pounds,
50 pounds.
He said like what the fuck's a poot.
Especially if you're like a little check,
but you've really liked gorillas and you're looking to get one m two poots that
shit's heavy as fuck.
You don't want me to swinging that around.
Go to on a.com use the code word Rogan and save 10% off any and all supplements
that we're selling.
And again,
$5 off of each orangutan kettle bell goes to help save or rank tents.
I'm done with saving.
Chimpanzees rang tans.
I'm done with all that.
I'm going with all of that man.
We're also sponsored by legal zoom.
Legal Zoom is a website that allows you to do a lot of things you would normally
have to go to a lawyer for and you,
you could do it all from your own computer.
Like Shit,
like,
uh,
incorporate form an LLC.
You can actually get divorced.
We're trying to get uncle creepy divorced through legal zoom.
Ian Mccall,
uh,
the MMA fighter was on the show.
He's trying to get legal zoom to do is divorce.
Um,
I think,
I think they'll down the problem.
You got to do it by yourself.
Essentially.
You've got to go through the process.
Um,
you know,
you have to fill out all the information,
but then once you do that,
if you get scrambled and you're like,
Oh shit,
I'm freaking out.
I don't think this is legal.
Legal Zoom will hook you up with an attorney.
They'll connect you with an independent attorney if you need additional
guidance.
So they want to emphasize at legal.
Zoom is not a law firm,
but they provide self-help service at your specific direction.
Meaning they let you understand and they,
they talk you through the process of creating legal documents like wills or LLCs
or things along those lines.
And even divorces,
use the codeword Rogan and save yourself some money.
Everlast is here,
Ladies and gentlemen,
my wrong thinking.
Robert Shapiro started that.
Or was he just in early like spokesperson?
Is that true?
I don't know.
Let's look that up.
I don't,
I have this sense.
This was the early spokesman or he might've started it.
Wow.
It was a smart move.
Yeah.
But that's one of those things where you go,
Ooh,
hmm.
Hmm.
Do I want to be a,
do I want to be connected with homeboy?
What is Mark Furhman do these days?
That'd be people don't find out like where people are like that aren't,
you know,
that notorious like people are,
yeah.
Let's see,
it says jumped to legal zoom here.
I guess he had something to do with it.
Shapiro's one of the cofounders of legals
Everlast deep inside the system,
understanding all the behind the scenes.
I just haven't smoked up that part of the brain yet.
Dog and I saw that's a wrong,
there was still a little Shapiro [inaudible] Shapiro knowledge left there
somehow eat some fresh fruits and vegetables.
I still live in like the car chase is going on like oh
I'm living in the nineties brother hit the music.
Hi.
I
already did it.
So it was officially started.
Yeah,
it good enough.
We don't need all that music.
Fuck,
we're going to have plenty of music in this podcast but don't really need the
opening song.
Yeah.
That Oj thing is uh,
one of the weirdest times in my life because I was a very young man and I was
still really delusional about the way the world worked.
I really had no idea.
You know,
I didn't know like to the extent of corruption and craziness and the,
the,
the fucking dispute between like when Rodney King happened and I saw like how
strong the hate for polices and the,
the,
the anger that led to the writing.
I was like,
who the fuck saw that come and who thought that I was so delusional?
Like I had such little contact with that world that I had no idea what the
disparity wasn't like Holly's people felt about about the police brutality and
things like that.
And you see that video of them beating the shit out of that dude with sticks and
then they got off and everybody's like,
Whoa,
wait a minute.
You're like,
what?
How,
what's going?
What happened here?
Exactly.
Okay.
He was on what he said he's on,
he's on like angel dust so he doesn't feel it.
Is that what's happening here?
Do they have something that they can,
can they hold on
to him?
Like he's five guys,
can't they Russell this due to the ground?
Like,
it seems like,
it seems like they having a good time for me,
shit out of this.
The myth of like,
or not the myth,
but the grand thing about deal.
Yeah.
Angel Dust.
That's the one thing they say like,
Yo,
people are broken out of handcuffs.
If that's the case,
people need to revisit that fucking,
that one particular issue because uh,
Angel that I have a friend who had his finger bitten off man.
It wasn't,
that was just the straw dude.
You know what I mean?
That was just a straw on the camel's back was it's damn near snapped at that
point.
I was living on that side of the world.
I was like part of the ice,
these riots in the kid I was running through.
It was like,
I knew the hatred for the police was,
was that was like I was,
I was,
you know,
normal.
What was it like rolling around with those guys?
You know what the thing was is like,
in a weird way,
I was just so oblivious to it that I,
you know,
cause I was treated as it,
like I was a member of the crew was already one of that rap kid and it was like,
you know,
I,
as long as I showed them,
had the balls to be somewhere,
I felt like I was cool there.
You know?
I mean,
I was like,
I,
and I was,
I never,
I wasn't into gang bang and everything.
I never flag in anywhere.
I was,
you know,
but,
and I always,
you know,
and I was,
knew a few key people that would be like,
oh yeah,
like if he knows that dude.
All right too.
That was a huge ice tea fan.
I used to get told like they used by like Castlight guys,
ice would say things like,
you know,
yeah man,
you're white man.
Everybody here either thinks you're crazy for being here or you're a cop.
So it's good.
You're good.
So two nights,
that was one.
Yeah.
Well,
you know what,
man has his best shit.
Well,
I think colors is one of his best songs ever.
That is one of the best like theme songs for a movie representative of what was
going on in that movie.
That,
that,
that song just fucking nailed it.
That was right place,
right time,
right dude.
You know what I mean?
Whoever,
whoever picked him for that,
it was the right if everybody made the right decision.
That's the rap version of live and let die.
That's a good thought.
Live and let die.
It's just a theme song for a movie.
Right?
But it's a bad ass fucking song.
I mean,
Dada,
this original purpose,
the original purpose,
it was a theme for Homie.
I believe Paul Mccartney made it for the movie.
Unless it was just,
oh no,
I can,
uh,
just a coincidence that he had a song called live and let die and there was a
double o seven movie,
let's say.
Okay,
let's find out.
We need to find Paul Mccartney.
You Fan of Paul Mccartney.
I mean,
as a songwriter,
how could you not be right?
I mean the guy's written a lot of amazing songs.
You know,
you,
you aspire to write that many well known songs,
you know,
he was a beast,
I mean I think there's like,
cause you seem like such a nice guy.
I think like some more hardcore people don't give that guy the credit he
deserves.
Like,
like for me,
like if you look at the Beatles,
you break them down.
It's like Paul John Lennon wrote the more ethereal kind of Weirdo kind of songs
or like more government related protest.
He kind of stuff.
Paul Mccartney wrote this stuff about love and life every day.
Things,
you know what I mean?
And like turning him in the poetry kind of thing.
You know,
that's,
you know,
I think there are,
I love them both in different ways.
Perfectly sad.
He was commissioned specifically for this movie and credited to McCartney.
His wife Linda reunited the former Beatles producer George Martin who bought
produce a song and it brings the orchestra break.
It was all done for,
uh,
for that movie.
This is one of the most successful like movie theme songs ever.
Cause it was a real song.
Yeah.
And then guns and roses,
we cut it and yeah,
so 10 million records.
That's how fucking bad ass song for your theme song,
your movies making $100 million no matter what.
Just what that song on it.
Yeah.
You know it can't go wrong.
And then band on the run,
that's like,
that's a crazy song.
That's like two songs in one.
You know,
like you,
you listen to the beginning of it.
And then when the rain exploded with a mighty crash as we fell into the sun,
God Damn Paul Mccartney.
I mean that's a beautiful fucking song.
It's a work of art and good drugs.
Oh fuck.
Yeah.
He'd seen everything there is to say.
He saw the full month of saw that happened as he,
as he fell into the sun,
he saw that happen.
Well,
rain exploded with a mighty crash as we fell into the sun.
Damn.
You know,
he had to have seen all of that.
That's a mold.
I can hear the colors,
I can hear the creditors,
man.
He can't write something like that unless you've seen something like that.
You can't fake that lyric.
The rain exploded with a mighty crash as we fell into this son.
What the fuck?
The first one to said to the second one there,
I hope you're having fun.
That is psychedelic as a lyric ever can get without being like ponderous.
You know what I mean?
Without being like blatantly obvious or trying to be like trippy like that is
just,
there's,
that's a perfect lyric.
Well the rain exploded with a mighty crash as we fell into the sun and the first
one said to the second one there,
I hope you're having fun.
What kind of Shit are you onsite on?
Acid for real.
It has to be right.
Heavy doses of it.
It's such a trippy lyric.
He was so there that that band was so instrumental in opening people's minds to
the ideas of altered states of consciousness because they were so into like
meditation and you know,
there was always hanging out with weird gurus and shit.
They were freaky dudes,
man.
And they started off like these really sweet guys from England was cute haircuts
making girls scream and then somewhere along may morphed into this like
spiritual injection machine.
You know,
like if you go back to the white album,
like some,
like you,
if you became a fan of the Beatles,
he became a fan of like very strange alternate ways of thinking,
you know?
Yeah.
You saw at this time if you were a fan morphing with them.
You had to be pretty open minded.
Yeah.
You know,
luckily the music was just really good,
so it helped a
lot.
I think that you had to be that good.
You can say some really,
really stupid shit on a bit of music.
That sounds good.
I mean,
and that proof is all around us today.
All around us always will be.
But I think to be that good,
you have to get crazy.
And I think they got crazy.
They just went everywhere.
They just went with it.
And there's no way,
you know,
you can't,
it's,
that's not a regular dude.
If I could do is not going to make that song.
It's not,
it's literally not possible.
Like did the mind does not work that way.
If you're,
you got to be some crazy dude out there wearing robes,
hanging out with dudes and Tibet for real.
You don't say tars
and be a perfectionist.
You got to have good roots and shit.
Indian dudes would white beards and they'd tell you freaky shit.
But also the cats didn't have the benefits of computer technology,
man.
They have to be good at all of the shit they were doing.
Yeah,
totally true.
Yeah.
Now I do days a guy could grab this guitar completely that attuned and like
strum it on it a little bit and,
and literally in the,
in the box make it sound like he was doing something.
Do you think that that cheapens music or is it d just give an artist more tools?
Um,
is it obvious?
More cheapens it.
I think it could,
it could do what you do.
You know,
it's a double,
it's a double edged sword.
I mean,
you know,
but when it's just used like to blatantly like suck the light.
Yeah.
We talk about something like,
you know,
like we'll hit,
we'll listen to old records that were like sampled and made into hip hop
records.
Like I don't bite before we go on.
I lacked,
I listen to a lot of old music when we play,
so we'll listen to the old versions of stuff and then we'll put on new versions
and new versions.
Even though they're sampled or using pieces of that old version,
they don't have the grease because it's not alive.
There's not five guys locking up playing it.
It's like a machine.
Here's a piece,
piece piece,
and then we repeat that piece piece piece,
and then we can repeat that piece piece piece.
It's like sucks the life out of things sometimes.
You know what I mean?
It's,
it's good for,
I mean like for club music,
if you're just making like drum machine club music or hip hop,
you know what I mean?
Like,
you know,
it sounds good in clubs,
but it's not,
you know,
it's not really,
it doesn't have no grease.
You know,
the first time I ever saw a rapper in a club was in Mexico.
I saw ludicrous perform in Mexico.
He was like an hour late,
you know like all that's early.
That's early for a rapper.
Everybody's like waiting for the show stuff.
But damn man,
when he,
when he did it and it was like complete short attention span rap,
like you never really finish a rap.
He just went from one wrap to the other,
like shorten,
shorten the songs up.
And I was like,
that's kind of crazy.
I'm like,
how often did they do that?
And my friend was like,
they always do that at hip hop shows and I go,
why?
And he goes,
they just don't want to give anybody any breaks.
No,
no chance to like think that things are calming down and no chance.
Like it just,
just go,
go,
go.
They're like,
it's a different,
it's a different environment than playing a record.
Bless.
You never know when it,
when you play clubs like when it's just all going to go wrong anyways.
You want to get the bulk of your set in so you're,
you know,
you're getting paid well.
Does that the case in like rap shows in general?
Just like,
no,
it's just like that's the energy or the energy of a ramp show is,
it's different than unless,
you know you got rappers and certain cats that use bands now,
but it's like when you go and you see a show that has a band,
there's things to see and watch and wonder about in like,
wow,
that sound and these guys are all doing crazy thing,
you know?
But when it's like just a Dj and a rapper,
that can get boring real quick just watching it.
So did you did,
yeah,
they just got to hit you in Hitchin when hits you and hits you,
we'd like me.
It's medley time is really what it is.
It's all about the medically in hip hop and plus it's like a ringtone
generation.
So they want to hear,
you know,
most of them only know the song up until the ringtone cuts off.
Wow.
How does that,
what does that say about us?
I'm serious,
but it's true.
Look,
I know you get about a minute and a half or something.
I think when you are a minute of a ringtone,
you know that's,
that's basically what they,
when you,
I,
I occasionally Dj like a Columbia here and there in Vegas when,
you know,
when,
when they throw out a couple of dollars and I say I'm bored enough and it's
because I think it's fun,
but I don't think I ever get out of a first verse of a record.
Well very rarely,
and it's usually a classic like Dr Dre,
you know,
a next episode or something like that or you know,
jump around or,
you know,
and not to toot my horn,
I'm just saying it's usually a classic record like that you can get away with
playing a few verses of,
otherwise it's just like kind of like one hook,
one verse,
one hooked went,
let's get out and get to the next thing for it.
Cause it's,
that's the dance that they want to dance.
They want to move.
They want to just always be like,
oh they always want to be like the next song came on.
Yeah.
Wow.
The party's got to be beginning like every five minutes.
So it's different than,
than doing your songs just in a,
in a live session like you do when you come see me doing acoustic show,
I take my motherfucking sweet time about it,
man.
And I,
and I,
you know,
I might even start mumbling while I drink whiskey and wind up telling a story I
never meant to tell in the first place.
Right.
It's a different thing.
What do you like better?
Okay.
Um,
rationals are,
and we're fun.
I did plenty of them,
but I enjoy what I do.
I like playing music.
I like locking in with people and other musicians and us creating,
like they play my songs the way they should be played.
But yeah,
if you listen enough,
like think different things happen every night and we're all fitting in with
different,
you know,
without prying,
without changing the song you,
there's things going on that,
um,
you know,
I'll be like,
oh,
I saw what you did right there and oh we are our own or we'll all just black out
and zone in some other place and it's trans transcend transcendental it,
when does that the right word?
Transcendent,
transcendent send it.
I mean you just kind of,
it's the energy of the music.
I liked that a little bit better.
I got,
you know,
hip hop is,
the energy is kind of a one,
it's kind of a steady Masha heavily angry.
Even even when it's like trying to be slowed down and love songs,
they're like heavily angry towards,
towards the women.
They're talking about this as long as my bitches love me,
bitches love me.
It was like,
okay.
I mean I'm sitting here and I'm,
I have that on in the car and I'm like,
oh this is a funny,
cool song.
I like it.
It's cool.
But it's like not think about is like if I were to like that to me like abroad,
as long as my teachers love me and bitches,
I don't know.
Who knows?
Maybe then I went,
sent him sell 10 million records and that should be my next effort.
Maybe just too happy and successful.
Maybe we need to tune into pissed off people that are all,
no fucking,
I'm pretty pissed off.
Yeah,
that the aggression of rap music is like,
I mean there's like Noah,
there's never been an art form where people bragged about like killing people
and got killing the police and like you know it was just running around making
millions.
Dogs are a little bit of Johnny Cash Rock Man.
There's some punk rock shit that was pretty out there.
That's true.
Well I was never exposed to that.
I for whatever reason,
never had any desire to listen to any punk rock.
I always,
I mean it's totally prejudice but I always associated everybody who was like a
punk rock lever with like misplaced anger and I was like just,
I don't have time for this.
I got to get away.
Like for real,
I've never lived,
I listened and it's totally ignorant and I completely agree.
I mean like,
uh,
admitted but you never listen to ash or anything like that I guess.
Is that punk rock?
The Casbah is that punk?
There's arguments that that's their most pop stuff,
you know,
I just thought it was great music and once I didn't London calling,
but had lots of songs like the guns of Brixton and all kinds of stuff about,
you mean what is punk though?
I don't understand it.
I just,
I was associated with people with their hair,
like all spiked up and you know,
looking to stomp around and shit.
I feel like punk is like a DIY thing.
Like it's like the sentiment,
you're going to put that out there before you even know how to play.
You're just like,
hey,
lump on,
I want to do a song.
I can't play.
Like all those like guitar,
God's back in the day.
So instead I want to just plug in and turn up and like,
I know two,
so two courts,
hey,
here's a song.
That's it.
It's not really all punk kids.
That's odd.
So it's bullshit.
It's bullshit.
It's bullshit with like balls,
bullshit with ball and like the mentality,
you know,
cause like they couldn't play as good.
The purist American music.
Yeah.
Actually,
you know,
cause it kind of started,
I,
some people argue it started in England,
but it's,
well yeah,
I say attitude of,
of of bullshit with balls.
Yes.
That's,
that's,
that's why it's so American.
It's so beautiful.
Is that American music or it's got a lot of people just got into art too.
You know what I mean?
Like,
you know,
I mean black flag,
which was produced Henry Rollins and
cats like that,
you know,
and you know,
I mean then there's,
you,
there's the spectrum is wide too because there's people like
GG Allen Shit.
I was just like,
he'd come in and throw himself through a glass window and take a shit on stage.
She wasn't even about the music,
but it was punk.
Rock punk is like an umbrella,
you know,
it's like hip hop,
you know there's like art,
punk,
art,
fashion expression
and rebellion and admitting that you're,
or accepting and in and sort of being enthusiastic about the fact that you're
rebelling
against the system.
I was from the burbs,
so I took it as a bunch of angry burbs kids.
I couldn't like do shit and express anything.
So instead they just like,
you know,
it was just like anger,
like,
well you said misplaced anger,
but it seeps into politics.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
Punk is a weird thing because I wasn't really a part of punk as a scene when it
was happening.
I learned about it later,
you know what I mean?
And that kind of,
I look at it from a standpoint of the band's not that like fans,
you know what I mean?
There was a lot of smart bands,
you know,
food guys eating and stuff like that.
The whole DC scene,
bad brains is like responsible for like half of the hardcore music.
Do you like hardcore bands?
Like,
you know,
and I'll guarantee you any of them somewhere.
So if the not them,
whoever influenced them was influenced by bad brains.
The first band to play fast that like fast pumps
but could play and they were like reggae looking Rastafar I'd do this plan
hardcore like punk music.
It was,
it was ill is suicidal tendencies is that pump?
Yes.
Okay.
Well I love those dudes.
That song bring me down.
You can't bring me down.
God Damn is that a good workout song?
Music like that's aggressive fucking song.
There's a ton of like just whatever.
But there's some really good stuff out there.
Punk rock me,
rock punk doesn't even exist anymore really.
You know what,
anything that call up punk now.
It's Kinda just like a marketing ploy or Chile or trying to be what punk once
was in my opinion.
But if you're doing blues,
are you trying to be what blues once was absolutely everybody at?
Absolutely.
I mean that's like saying,
okay,
if I try to make blues,
am I really fucking like some Delta fucking cotton picker?
Fucking know I'm,
I'm emulating something.
You know what I mean?
But you're a dude who's lived,
but I'm just saying,
it's like you got the,
at the purest form of what that music and where it came from.
It's like,
no,
I'm not that guy that invented,
you know,
I didn't invite that.
I'm just saying it's a formula that it was there long before me and I'm just
kind of using it to express myself.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
But it's still,
you're doing blues,
you know,
and I think in it's in it's,
and it's,
when it was happening was an original thing.
It hadn't been seen or done before.
And they still do punk.
They do.
I'm just saying it's not still,
you can stay seen.
I ain't seen nothing.
That was that.
I would put it this way.
I ain't seen nothing.
New punk rock,
everything that causes cell punk rock is like kind of a retro version of what
used to be punk rock know.
But I'll tell you the most punk rock thing I've seen in a long,
long fucking time.
I've watched the guy's ass.
No,
no,
no.
I watched the fucking documentary on those pussy riot chicks.
Oh,
those pictures are crazy.
I frequency writes gangsters,
gangsters,
man in the courts and right in the face of the Russian government.
Then broad stood tall.
I'm like,
Yo,
whatever you want to feel about them.
I think what they should do,
all that shit was just,
you know,
that's gangster.
That's,
they said something,
they did it.
They stood for it and they didn't even fold up.
This is pretty gangster.
I mean,
it was crazy.
I was like,
wow.
You know,
at a certain point in time you have to realize that these things that you're
calling churches are weird of behavior that
were established but people thousands of years ago and they have literally
nothing to do with God.
If there is a god without a doubt,
it has nothing to do with the bizarre behavior of these people that are claiming
to represent him and no one person can be represented by God or whatever the
idea of God is.
But then you can,
we're,
we're all supposedly in this together and as soon as you have leaders and people
who are in charge of organizations with very specific rules,
you've missed the boat completely.
You know,
you're,
you're in some weird,
cultish sort of a thing.
That's just what the fuck it is.
You know,
people don't want to say that.
They don't want to believe that,
but that's just what the fuck it is.
You know?
So when you,
when you limit people like that and you,
you box them up like that,
it said it's a dangerous thing.
It's always going to be a dangerous thing.
So I was going to be a dangerous thing to control people like you can't,
you gotta people got up just be nice to each other.
You can't be like,
eventually we're going to figure out these borders are bullshit.
Eventually we're going to look at all the borders all over the place.
I'll go a little bit,
blah,
blah.
Well,
why the fuck can can,
why can't we just go over there?
Why can't anybody to go wherever the fuck they want?
Would that force everybody to even out the economic situation of the world.
If people could just completely travel freely.
Like one of the reasons why you going to have ghettos is cause you can keep them
there.
You know,
if people could just go wherever the fuck they wanted to go,
they would just go wherever the money is.
People from Mexico just start walking into America and then you're going to have
to deal with that.
You're gonna have to deal with the fact that you connected to a third world
country and people from Canada going to have our assholes sneaking into their
borders and then goes,
okay,
well we've got to tighten down the fucking fences here.
What's going on?
We got these crazy asshole American
insanity are pretty tight buddy.
They are right now.
Right now if they open it up on a gun charge in 1992 I've like just started
getting in again like this year.
What'd you have to do to get in?
Uh,
jump through some hoops.
Money.
I had a friend who,
who goes to hold over for a gun and it wasn't even illegal.
He was legally in possession of a gun and every time he goes to Canada,
they pull him in that room and they sit him down.
I stay.
Ask them a hunter cross?
Yeah.
Huh?
They don't take kindly to it,
but if you would've got caught with 10 pounds of weed,
they don't trip that hard.
Go ahead Ted Pounds.
Go ahead.
Up in.
We're not worried about even smoke that much weed before it goes bad.
Sure.
10 pounds of weed die trying.
How many,
how many years is that of weed?
That's a few years of weed,
right?
Gotta be three weeks.
Unless you're just crazy.
Joey Diaz could smoke a pound a year.
More than that.
I'm trying to figure how much this,
how much is a pound?
I'm thinking of like an 18 ounces and then I'm thinking a 16 ounces in a pound.
That's not that much.
You can sell 160 ounces.
You get smoke that in a few months if you were going,
Joe De is style.
I've never even held a pound yet.
Neither have,
I don't want to be around a pound.
If you're read a pallet
like a house,
no days would probably last me a couple months.
Look back in the day I would've done had been,
it would probably,
it would have been about a week,
like two the head just from me.
Well pound,
no one else.
Oh Jesus.
So it would,
it took me 160 weeks.
10 yeah
he did that.
I probably smoked 10 pounds in 160 weeks.
That makes sense.
52 weeks a year I can do that.
Makes Sense.
I can do announce a month.
Yeah,
that totally makes sense.
That sounds it.
Wow.
That's really brilliant calculations actually.
That sounds like that's like some serious we'd economics you broke it down
probably.
Exactly.
That's no exaggeration in that there was no,
you know,
there's no hyperbole
because it was part of the money this week is all right.
400 for an ounce a week,
every week.
That was every week.
That was like my loan shark almost thing.
Cause sometimes I go in and be like,
give me three and I'll get you next week.
And,
uh,
you know,
so you had to be steady.
Which do you see the,
the changes that are happening right now about with weed?
Well,
we just did a thing in Seattle called hemp fest and it is wide the fuck open up
their dog.
We went to what?
What was it called?
The Dab.
A Bar?
Yeah.
Dab Dab dude.
Like do the waxy,
like bong hit shit.
But it was like a open bar open,
like open to the public.
Oh,
is that a picture of it?
It was like along the waterfront,
a three mile long festival.
Cops were handing out to retos a yeah.
My friend booty chicken told me about that.
What does that,
oh my God,
that's a lot of pot hemp fest did.
He showed me a picture of a door knob.
That's,
it looks like a donut.
Look at it.
All those joints,
it looks like a door knob and that'll be actually a cool door knob.
You take a photo of that and recreate it perfectly.
It's a lot of fucking joints.
What's a big tin of joints?
And it looks like a Dornier sitting on a door.
The pictures,
the pictures unusual because there's a wooden door that looks like it's like
the,
uh,
the table looks like a wooden door.
So this box on it,
it looks like a doorknob.
Yeah,
the prince.
A lot of goddamn joints.
Yeah.
I would get nervous.
I'd run out of the room.
If you had that,
I'd be like,
that's too much.
We're going to get busted for selling.
That's like if you have more than a certain amount.
They were just slinging weed and do not give,
they give zero fucks up in Seattle.
Seattle is a beautiful place.
I love it up there.
It's one of my favorite cities ever.
It's like they have to deal with some shit because of the,
the stinky weather in the winter.
But you know,
the roads don't really ice up,
you know,
you've got to look,
they're just cool with anything that's going to keep motherfuckers from jumping
out of windows and shit like,
well,
they're also really smart up there.
So real smart city,
like per capita,
very unusually smart because creating this stone,
one of the higher suicide rates because of the weather and whatnot.
Without a doubt.
Yeah.
This is not make you happy,
does not make you happy a lot.
A lot.
But that shit builds character.
It builds character drugs.
Not necessarily my making,
just a little more expressive.
I don't know if you felt trapped in it though,
man.
Like guys like you and me,
we could always be like,
fuck this.
I'm going,
I'm going to San Diego or I'm going to Hawaii for a week.
I'm out.
Yeah,
you could do that.
Yeah.
That and people who lived there,
they say if you can schedule a vacation,
you'd go in the winter and he goes somewhere where it's sunny period.
You know,
you don't do anything goofy,
you know you're not going to somewhere that's shitty or where you're at,
you know,
go somewhere cold.
You go to the beach,
bitch.
That's what you're doing.
I thought of it that way.
Like that would be cool to have like a Ho like live in Seattle and then just get
the fuck out of there.
If you get to totally be cool.
Be Cool to live in Seattle period.
Yeah.
I think you'd deal with the rain city.
The folks are good up there.
It's a very artistic city.
Like it just,
it doesn't seem like a city that has a lot of chains.
You know when you drive it through,
you see like a lot of individual restaurants,
individual stores to see a lot of unique to Seattle.
You know,
and I think that's one of the reasons why the music scene at a Seattle and Jimmy
motherfucking Hendrix came from Seattle respect.
Okay.
You know,
I mean everybody knows nirvana came from Seattle.
What is it like?
I don't know.
But that's the environment that created that,
those people,
you know what I'm saying?
Like there's an intensely creative environment that creative Ivana,
I mean that that band was intensely creative,
you know,
was also raped me like holy shit.
Like that whole sub pop records seen.
They were,
they were pretty much kind of music.
Were they?
That was all that stuff.
What,
what'd you call that growing big?
Called a [inaudible].
It was just rock and roll.
I mean they would,
they would have just called it rock and roll hardcore.
They started off punk.
They started up punk.
Yeah.
Wow.
Yeah,
they were fucking,
there was a hardcore music movement.
They called it hardcore after punk towards the end,
I'll never forget,
I forgot,
found out about Nirvana.
I was out where this dude's house that I used to buy stolen radios from.
That was this one dude,
if you needed to radio back then when I did understand Karma,
you know,
you need to radio from your car.
You can get one from,
uh,
this kid who always had radios.
Then it would just somehow or another get and you didn't ask any questions,
but you knew they were stolen.
Uh,
we were over his house and he was into music.
This kid,
it was just a bad kid,
you know,
whatever.
Bad suburban kid,
not too bad.
We went over his house and he goes,
this is going to change music.
I said,
what is it?
He goes,
it's called fucking Nevada.
And he starts playing it and he goes,
all those hairbands,
those guys are fucked.
And he played this shit.
I was like,
wow.
Like you just nailed it.
Like this kid nailed it in his,
in his bedroom in Newton,
Massachusetts.
Like right when the w nevermind came out.
This kid nailed it.
He just was an,
he was just a radio theater and he was like,
this is,
this is going to change.
This goes guys are fucked.
It was that obvious though.
It's that obvious.
Danny boy played it for me first.
Like I was like,
and we were both like,
yeah they draws dropped this only been a few times.
And like musical history when someone hits some new levels of something we that
you'd never seen it before.
And when Nirvana came out that was like,
Whoa,
I'm deniable talent.
Undeniable uniqueness.
The power of their songs.
Song after song.
Different honest though.
Yeah.
Oh totally honest,
honest,
raw and like this insane heroin way.
You know this insane heroin honesty spawned
by the punk movement.
Is that,
what is it about Alice and chains chains?
They weren't,
they were rounded like that.
They were more on the metal side to me,
but like they were definitely of that grunge ish metal movement to like sound
garden,
you know,
they like rocked out a little harder.
You know that song,
them bones,
she's Christ.
That makes you feel like you're dying when you're listening to it.
Jerry Cantrell's a beach.
That was the dude who was sad.
He that mother fucker understood that he was dying when he wrote that song.
He understood that he was on that path when he wrote that song and I don't
think,
I don't think lane rope tows.
He just sang it.
Yeah,
I think Jerry control road,
all that stuff.
Wow.
I'm pretty sure it whatever.
There may be a few that I'm wrong,
but at the bulk and the temper form that what I'm saying is like the way Layne
Staley hit notes like it made you like,
it made you feel that you were dying.
Like that song going to end up a big old pile.
Them bones like that screaming.
It was like Jesus Christ.
I remember the first time I saw a man in the box,
like on MTV.
It was like,
what the hell is that?
God Damn,
those guys were intense and it was crazy and that that kind of,
I had a night with that dude and and another guy,
Layne Staley.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I did.
It was good to know.
We just slowly,
sorry,
motor,
this promoter and Philly book,
this,
this place,
I believe it was the electric factory,
like you know,
thousand seater club,
something like that.
He booked it twice in one night.
He did two shows.
He didn't Alison change show early,
kicked everybody out than to the house painting show.
Well we showed out to the place twice in one night,
but we all,
because you know we were all at the same hotel,
so like we,
I saw these guys,
we were coming back from hotel,
me and Dj Lito and they were like,
Yo,
it was,
we were like,
Hey,
what's up?
We're going to go up to the room,
smoke one party a little bit.
They were like,
all right.
We came up,
him and his buddy and they came up and they sat at the table and we are rolling
joints and we're talking all this shit and like me and lethal to just rolling
all joint after joint,
throwing them out and say table.
And then we stopped and we go to light one and both the dudes are sitting there
just completely knotted out cold.
Wow.
Cigarette's burned into their fingers like,
and we were like,
what the fuck was,
we weren't really hit.
We were kind of naive,
you know what I mean?
We were like,
didn't realize they were on heroin,
you know what I mean?
By that time we had,
but it was like,
you know,
the whole time they were just like,
wow.
Sniffing or smoking shit out of a tin foil.
Like oh no,
I've done that before.
We even really joyous man.
You know what I'm say?
You didn't even realize they were doing it.
Nah,
it was like they were rolling in our presence for the matter of like 15 minutes.
Stone Temple pilots performed for Dana White as birthday party once.
And it was one of the best fucking live shows I've ever seen in my life.
Oh yeah.
Like we want to talk about some dudes who,
who like are solid professional.
I don't know if you know those guys are,
have any,
I've met him.
I couldn't tell you.
I don't like them.
I don't know if I'm going to go fuck themselves.
If you know you're tell me you don't like them.
I've met them at shows,
festivals kind of situations a couple of times I wouldn't seem like,
all right dudes,
I was blown away because it was a private party.
It wasn't that many people there.
There was like,
you know,
a couple hundred people maybe,
it was Dana's birthday party was all his friends and,
and you know,
I'm like,
you got stone temple fucking pilots to do this,
you know,
to the,
the people that did it,
like Dana didn't even know.
I don't think,
I'm pretty sure they did.
The whole,
the whole Party was a surprise.
So I don't think he knew that stone temple pilots was hired to play it for him.
I don't think he had any idea until we brought him out.
But to see stone temple pilots just rocket like there's 18,000 motherfuckers on
their feet.
I mean that that dude can fucking perform with a hundred whatever it was.
200 people in that room.
That guy went off.
It was magnetic.
I learned about performing,
watching him,
I felt like an amateur.
I was watching this guy like does his,
his,
his fucking,
his commitment to every step,
everything that he did that the energy to those songs.
I was like,
everything I do,
I suck at this guys.
This is,
this is incredible.
Yeah.
He doesn't check out.
Didn't check out at all.
It was,
it was interesting,
but it's obviously very different than your acoustic sets,
which are equally interesting.
This,
it's a weird thing that you could,
they could have two things that are completely different on the spectrum,
but both have like an equal impact because of their honesty.
Whether it's a beautiful acoustic song,
let's really emotional or whether it's that raped me song.
It's just like that.
It just hits that note,
whatever it is by any weird way.
It gets there but ain't fucking ups or downs,
whether it's depressing or you know,
or in enlightening whatever it is.
It's what he hits that note.
You know,
he got kicked out,
you know that.
Who did?
Scott Wayland.
I got kicked out of stone temple file probably for being too awesome.
Thanks for that.
Awesome.
It's pretty hard to work with regular people.
I went with drugs.
I went,
Oh shit.
Uh,
Dana did that once with Joan jet at the Viper Room.
Oh really?
Wow.
It was God.
I would love to see that a hundred people and she just did the same,
just rocked out.
Yeah.
But I know,
I know,
you know that check was beautiful.
I know what the stone temple pilots thing was.
I asked,
I can't tell,
but I asked.
It was very nice.
It's very nice evening for those gentlemen,
but I'm telling you,
they did not treat it like it was like,
uh,
a private party that they could like barely get there and barely do the show
for.
That's what blew me away.
It was like this dude was at a private party and you know,
I mean,
maybe he's a big UFC fan.
I don't know.
I don't know if that was part of his motivation,
but these motherfuckers nailed it.
I mean just destroyed,
you know?
I mean,
we were just people who weren't musicians like me and some of my other friends
would just look at each other going,
God Damn God damn.
How much Joe [inaudible] favorite band?
100 roses.
I can't tell you man.
It's confidential shit.
75 roads.
It's a lot of cash.
Sun,
they get [inaudible] son.
It's too bad.
Broke up.
But it doesn't that always happen.
It's like when you get a fat band together and they start kicking ass,
eventually it's fucking wheels fall off of that thing.
It's like how many bands here completely keep it together for a long period of
time.
It's like kiss and like how many,
and even though they lost ace freely and Peter Criss don't have like a fake ace
freely.
Yeah,
he is.
Gene Simmons is any needs Paul Stanley.
So yeah.
But I'm sure all kept in line dating.
Seemed like he,
uh,
he,
keeps things in,
in tight tow.
The only time I was ever nervous at a comedy show because someone was in the
audience,
Jean Simmons came to see me on New Year's and I was legitimately legitimately
shitting my pants because I'm a huge,
when I was a kid,
my uncle actually worked for Howard marks advertising and they're the guys who
used to make the ads and the album covers for kiss.
And uh,
so I made,
I met ace freely when I was like six,
seven,
seven years old,
six years old.
I was a little kid and he had no makeup on and I was like,
just getting into kiss back then and I couldn't believe that I'm looking at him
and he's got no makeup on because my uncle had like give me his records and I'd
listened to the songs.
I,
I became a fan because my uncle would give me free kiss records.
Like that's,
so seeing him with no makeup on,
it was like,
to me it was a real freak out.
So having Gene Simmons in the audience.
Even when I was 40 years old,
I was still like,
Yikes,
this is weird man.
That's gene fucking Simmons.
Gene Simmons from kiss.
I saw him,
I saw them when I was a kid.
I saw them when I was like seven or eight years old and I saw them again when I
was like 25 me and Kevin James who is a huge kiss fan,
I believe Kevin James is a huge kiss fan and me and Kevin James,
we went to two shows.
We went to two shows when they came back to La with a full kiss with Peter Criss
and ace freely in makeup and we were like,
you just complete unapologetic dorks.
We were reliving our childhood together,
unapologetically rocking out to a kiss concert and it to Chris.
I mean he was air guitar and Kevin James is fun to go to a fucking kiss concert
with cause he fucking sings the songs.
He like gets into it and this is back before people knew who he was,
he wouldn't be able to do that.
Now you have like a scene in one of his movies where that's what he's doing.
He's like,
oh sure.
Playing guitar hero or something.
I wished if somebody filled great rock city or something like that.
If somebody had filmed Kevin and I are going to seek kiss back in the day,
that would have been a fucking hilarious video because nobody knew who he was
back then.
This was before his TV show.
It was like he had was like a semi known comedian.
If you watch star search or something like that so he could be like free and
public and not worry about anybody.
Weird,
not him.
So he just completely rocked out Detroit.
Get down.
It was just like a free show.
No,
like especially like being a feller kiss fan.
It was awesome.
Kevin is fucking hilarious.
That guy's one of the funniest guys that doesn't get credit for it.
Like he's like real clean in his movies.
He's like squeaky clean and let you know his stand up is like,
he doesn't really talk about anything controversial,
but if you can hang out with that cash,
you hang out with that cat and get them to go full shimmy.
That's who we used to call him.
His nickname is shimmy.
We'd call it going full shammy where it gets fucking mad at things fro shit gets
red in the face and he's putting on a show for you.
You know,
he's,
he's doing a bit,
some of the funniest,
the hardest I've ever laughed.
It's just hanging out with him.
Like,
like having him recreating an argument that he had with his girlfriend,
you know,
like,
and him going crazy and red in the face.
He was a,
he's a fucking hilarious dude,
but he does movies that are like more like for families and kids.
Some people don't get to see that aspect of him too bad,
you know,
we don't want to balance to world.
We don't want to do to do kids' movies and still,
you know,
that's why we should have him on the podcast for sure.
He wouldn't do it.
Saget was one of the dirtiest comics ever used to be.
Yeah.
And I guess he was full House for,
he was like the full House Guy.
I think he stopped doing standard during that time.
Yeah.
Now he's super dirty and playing off the full house.
That's back to the dirty thing.
Yeah.
I think they probably told them,
hey dude,
this is like a hundred million dollar business we're running here.
Do you understand that?
And you could fuck that up by telling a Dick joke at the laugh factory.
So why don't you just lay off that you're getting,
you know,
x amount of millions a week.
And I always a,
and they did that with Tim Allen as well.
They told Tim Allen and stopped doing a stand up because it was a little
controversial.
I Dunno.
It's crazy.
And that's TV though.
All I know is I never got successful enough for anybody bother telling me to
stop doing that.
Eddie,
they go write me a check.
I have to do things when they start writing you checks not to do things.
You're doing something right,
man.
Well,
I never got,
I was never important enough in the equation where they asked me to not do
something like it was going to fuck things up.
You know,
like I guess like when fear factor came along,
people will already sort of opening up to the idea that the world isn't exactly
as we've been told and that there's a lot more variation in people then you
would like to imagine.
And you know the world's a big fucking place.
And of course,
how could a dick joke fuck up a show where somebody who's going to eat like
goat,
Dick.
You know what I mean?
It's also you can express yourself now before where if you said something fucked
up a long time ago,
you had to get booked on the tonight show to explain yourself.
You know,
I remember like when Hugh Grant got caught with the hooker and it was like the
big thing and he went and Jay Leno,
well what the hell were you thinking?
He gets it.
He could just do a video blog now.
You know what I'm saying?
Like instantly have something where expresses himself.
Now there's like,
there's so much range for expression now.
There's so much room,
it's just a completely different world.
You still have to apologize if you're Hugh grant though.
Like you certain comedians like wouldn't have to apologize,
right?
Yeah.
Well the guy like Hugh grant is selling that thing.
He's selling that.
This one style is just as Kevin is selling,
you know the squeaky clean family comedy.
You know Hugh grant was telling the really sweet boyfriend guy who was from
England and we'd like to help you move.
Can I caviol
couch and who's not some crazy dude looking to get his dick sucked on the sneak
tip
already.
Street hooker.
There's that too,
but okay.
You just reminded me of something.
There's that English dude on CNN with the glasses who still on,
but like three years ago the dude got caught like in central park,
like with meth in his pocket and I'm like a noose around his cock and like all
kinds of crazy shit.
It's Richard something.
Richard the British dude.
You would all know him when you see him.
God's,
yeah.
What's his name again?
Richard something.
CNN.
Richard.
Okay,
so I'm going to Google CNN.
Richard,
never last.
Drop in facts again.
What was the,
my brain works in crazy ways.
How about news?
A reporter reporter.
Noose around Cox.
See what comes up.
I'm going to have to say penis.
Look,
here's Hugh grant's differ now because it's Google.
That's right now.
Yeah,
she's sweet.
She's got a family family.
Sure.
She parlayed that into a life.
Okay.
I'm the streets.
I don't see it here under that.
So the story really is Hugh grant got someone off the streets.
So reporter arrested math.
Did you say math?
Yeah.
Math central park.
Here's,
here's a America.
Richard.
Fuck.
What the fuck is his name?
Richard something.
It does American Eagle.
That is dangerous.
What is this?
What do you watching his Mexicans USA and it killed.
That was an American Eagle.
Check this out that it ran into the window.
Yeah.
No,
the died.
I think it was supposed,
you know it's a show.
It was like,
oh,
it's a show.
I think so.
Oh,
you nailed the window at full clip.
Yeah,
they die all the time like that.
In my house.
Birds.
Birds are flying in my window.
They just fly any window.
Sometimes they miss.
They don't realize what it is.
Yes.
It's always sparrows.
Cute little things too.
It sucks.
I know there's,
does that mean you could do to get rid of it?
Like a grilling?
Yeah.
Dunkin did it throw them in the trash?
No,
I forget.
What did he say?
Hmm.
Yeah.
I don't know what,
what you can do,
but I remember he said he had a bird feeder and he had all these birds hitting
his window.
I found a story,
a CNN reporter arrested in central park.
What was named Richard,
what do you do to Richard Quest?
Richard quest was officially arrested for loitering and drug possession in the,
in the,
in Europe,
especially CNN like over there,
he's like on all the time this guy got arrested like with uh,
like something tied around his junk with math,
like on like some rampage.
Well it says the New York Post included this Kinky,
the kinky elements and an article on Saturday.
So there was some kinky elements to it is around his cock.
I like man.
Okay.
Yeah.
It says,
another website will tell the full story.
Why do they withhold information and say the guy got a noose around his dick in
the Ed math.
Don't say there's like,
but it's like student students didn't,
he didn't skip a step.
CNN didn't fire him.
They were just like,
all right,
Yo,
uh,
good for him.
It's just crazy talented.
This is strike one.
He's a good looking guy.
Okay.
So Richard Quest was arrested early Friday morning for drug possession when
people found in central park while after the parks 1:00 AM curfew.
Wow.
You know what?
Well,
so what cal was out getting his freak on.
I'm just saying he's a media guy.
I mean,
you'd think normally,
yeah.
It wouldn't normally get them fired,
but maybe he's really good at what he does.
And so they're like,
what happened?
Does like really corny kind of stories,
man.
He just like,
I'm under a lot of pressure.
I have a feeling,
you know,
maybe whoever he was going to meet with the math and the,
and the noose around his cock might be a superior at that.
His job or something that's so funny.
Can't lose it.
It wasn't immediately clear what the rope was for.
The officer on the scene was
see the drug because of his prior experience as a police officer in drug
arrests.
Okay,
so the guy had a package of math and he was headed home to his friend's house.
It says his lawyer claims that Qwest was returning to his hotel with friends and
had no idea there was a curfew for the park.
I didn't know it was a curfew for the parking,
did I?
That's kind of weird.
Isn't that like the whole thing about New York City so you could do whatever the
fuck you want?
No,
it's everything's open.
I think that stopped when people started winding up dead in the barn.
No weird.
You can't have woods.
Even woods in the city.
People start killing people and dragging them into bushes and chest were so
creepy.
When it comes to woods,
what is that about?
You know,
like women don't that women worry much more about getting like raped or attacked
in the woods.
Like if you find men in the woods like it's way more dangerous than the man in
the city,
any rape with probably all the same.
What about worrying about it?
Like if you ran into a man,
it's just you and the man in the woods.
It's way more of a rapey situation.
Then you run into a man in a city where there's all sorts of other people and
all sorts of buildings,
and when you're out there in the woods,
it's a totally different environment.
For a woman,
it must be,
you must feel like ultra violent,
like,
like ultra violent dudes that you could just stumble upon are super fucking
dangerous if you're a woman.
Whereas if you're a guy,
they're not going to fuck you.
They're going to look at you and go,
Hey,
here's another guy camping.
You know,
if you're a woman and you're out there in the woods by yourself,
unless you seen deliverance,
I think that that movie is accurate.
There are people that are out there.
May I see other guys even when I'm camping,
if they're not familiar,
I I start thinking rapey thoughts like,
hey man,
I'm trying to get raped out here.
We did bring a pistol,
right?
Yeah,
I would.
I really believe people get ready when it does.
Just out in nature.
Something prime who takes over man,
they get more in touch with their animal natures.
Yeah.
It's almost like with creating cities and spacing things and putting doors in
front of this and you can lock that and you're secure in this room instead of
like being all out in the open,
like we've like slowly moved away from the,
the,
the primal instincts that have driven us to this point.
But all you need is this room moved those buildings.
Yep.
Stuff.
Everybody back in the trees again and the same shit.
We'll start from scratch like really quick.
The moment your kids start getting hungry,
shit gets really fucking primal real quick.
That's what I keep telling people.
Yeah.
Well nobody wants to believe that,
that our civilization is just a thin veneer covering ancient barbaric genetics.
Our civilization in the last couple hundred years to really,
but if you go back to the fucking race riots in the,
in the 60s and the fifties like,
isn't that like what,
what kind of civilization is at what kind of civilization where they were just
like completely discriminated against someone for the color of their skin.
With all the books that were available.
They had decided these people who are less than they were going to keep them at
a certain bathrooms.
It tells us to fucking 1950s my grandma had,
you know,
like separate schools.
My grandma and she's Mexican.
Jesus.
So how,
how much civilization have,
we're really had,
how long has it really been around?
No,
it's fucking barely here.
It's barely here hanging on with vaccines and cell phones.
Barely here.
But if the fucking power goes off or a big rock hits the ocean or one of those
fucking volcanoes blows all or flare right back to 1,010 thousand years ago.
Right back real quick.
Soon as we run out of lighters,
soon as you run out of bullets,
right back to Craig.
Take me a while to run out of bullets,
just so everybody know
you hunt or do you just shoot targets?
And Brian and I are actually very curious lately.
We're trying to find one.
Probably take a class on how to like,
you know,
go hunt and like actually killing and prepare an animal properly.
You should go on Steve Rinella show.
You should go on that meat eaters show.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I'm not familiar,
but I want to,
you know,
I,
plus I always feel,
I feel like this as a meat eater,
I feel like I have the responsibility to actually have to go through and do
butcher an animal once and I've never had to do it in my life.
I understand it.
I've seen it on film,
but it's like I still feel like if I can't do it,
if I can't stomach doing it,
I have no business eating meat.
I feel the same way.
That was my motivation to go a hunt with him.
Yeah.
I want it to a experience it and I wanted to experience it with a completely
wild,
we took a canoe,
we went down to Missouri breaks,
we went on the Missouri River.
It was amazing.
Cause then I'm game was,
it was beautiful.
It's hard work though,
man.
You're,
you're,
you're huffing it over these hills.
Like if you're out of shape,
it's really hard because you're doing a lot of high elevation hiking and it
doesn't seem like notch because you're walking kind of slow,
but you don't fucking stop and dude's in serious shape cause he doesn't shut all
the time.
He hunts every day.
Like he's,
his show is a hunting show.
So he's always in fucking New Zealand climbing mountains.
He's like,
he's constantly doing this.
So it's like he's got this kind of hiking and Darren's,
it's a lot of work.
But the,
the experience of doing it was
life changing.
You know?
That's where I got that thing from.
That's deer head right there.
How much did that doorway?
Hundred 80 pounds.
Wow.
About approximately how long did the big um,
I ate it pretty quick.
Um,
quite the carnivore
eating like meat.
I just look,
I mean,
and I'm not a cruel person and I love animals and that seems like a
contradiction.
No it doesn't.
It's not,
people got to realize it.
You have to manage certain amount of wildlife.
You have to for their health,
for the health of the species,
like the idea of deer entitled like in total,
like the idea of large populations of deer and healthy animals breeding and
surviving in the wild around us is a beautiful idea.
But if you don't manage their numbers,
they just start breeding like crazy.
And then you slam into him with cars and then they run out of food.
They starved to death,
they started getting diseases,
those diseases transferred to people like it's,
uh,
it,
it really is as stewards of the land,
which is what humans claim to be,
you know,
if we start putting fences up around things and putting roads,
we're essentially saying,
we got this,
this is our spot.
Well,
you need to manage that wildlife.
You have to,
you have to kill them.
You,
your options are either kill them or reintroduced predators.
And they've tried both.
They reintroduced predators to Yellowstone and now they have real issues because
of the decimation of the elk population and the deer population.
There's like a fraction of the elk and deer that used to exist because they have
these big packs of wolves now and they're fucking successful because they don't
have much competition.
The grizzly bears don't know what the fuck's common,
you know,
and the grizzlies are not trying to eat the wolves and the wolves aren't trying
to eat the grizzlies and occasionally have to fight over a carcass or something
like that.
But for the most part there's a lot of shit that they're killing out there.
So that's,
that was one solution.
But now a guy in Minnesota got fucking beat in the head by a wolf.
His kid was camping the other day and this will fucking clamp to hold of his
head and just trying to drag him away and he's screaming and you know,
eventually prize himself free and they find the wolf and trap it and shoot it.
But like that's what happens when you don't hunt deer.
When you don't hunt deer,
you have to have wolves.
Okay.
And if you have wolves,
like they're gonna kill a few people every now and again.
I like,
well
I like wells but I wouldn't want him in my backyard.
I believe in calling of herds.
Yeah.
You got call.
Who's going to tell?
So the readout of delicious Lyme disease going to call ours?
That's a good question.
You know what I mean?
That is the question,
right?
Who's going to call ours?
That's the real question.
There really is the question.
Because if you,
you know,
like I've said to to certain people,
like you know,
if everybody just had less children in the world would be a beautiful place.
Like is that really true?
Okay.
Because you got to look at it a few ways.
One,
you got to look at it and aren't people,
they started out as children.
Okay.
We need people like wait,
what we without a doubt need to manage like the amount of us we have.
But don't you like people like I think people are awesome.
Like it's operation are the ones,
I'm not a lot of good ones man.
I've let a lot of good ones.
Like I'm a big fan of people.
So when someone says that we go to overpopulation problem,
I go right,
how do we right now,
like it seems now if everything stays
like this,
we got it.
I saw something online that was like this little graphic thing.
Like when they were taking senses about like every person on the planet
supposedly could fit in the state of Texas and with with elbow.
Yeah,
I've heard that too.
So it smells like shit.
It would be a real problem.
There's enough room for everybody.
Resources.
That's the,
that's the question.
Is there enough resell location of resource and that is the question.
Scarcity,
the issue of scarcity.
I was watching something today just before I came here that,
you know this show modern marvel,
Marvel's it's always an one and they were like doing this thing about,
you know,
city sewers and,
and bridges and all the stuff that's falling apart.
And it scared the life out of me because I spend my life traveling.
We've guys in cars and buses and on bridges and shit like that.
So,
but they were showing how this in St Louis,
they're doing this thing with this,
they're putting these tubes down into the sewers and they're blowing them up and
they go all the way down the sewer and then they heat them up and there's an
epoxy on the outside of them and they make plastic pipes inside the old decrepit
and it's,
and it's like,
I see it and it's so simple and so genius and it's like,
man,
what,
who didn't think of why it took them till 2013 to figure out how to figure out
how to do that.
You know what I mean?
It's just weird to me.
Like I think that about stupid shit too.
Like I saw a thing on the commercial where the,
there's a plug now that we're,
the thing actually goes to the sides so you could put shit flat out.
I was like,
it took until 2013 to come up with that.
Yeah.
Well if it was up to me,
we would never invented scissors.
I wouldn't have it figured out.
Scissors.
I'd be like,
she's fucking could it.
That's the problem.
I'm so stupid.
I can't imagine a laptop like I know I have one.
I know how to press buttons on it.
Imagine what the fuck is going on behind the scenes,
but that is the wizard of Oz right there.
You laptop was the wizard of Oz.
Who knows what the fuck is happening behind that curtain?
You're just on Facebook.
Oh mg lol.
Oh,
you can use the camera,
Huh?
No,
I don't care who y'all shut it off.
I want to take,
show me beating off you.
Go ahead and get it.
You fucks.
No,
no.
My body image isn't that great right now,
so I keep it.
Well,
nobody looks good when they're coming on themselves.
That's just a fact.
He just don't have it looks like that's what you should've done.
It always looks like you could have done some other shit.
You put up with shit to do that.
It's like if you're a grown man and you have a family and you have a life to
live,
you have businesses to run and shit.
Like how much time do you have for beaten off?
So every time you do it,
you feel like,
what the fuck the shame was,
the fuck is wrong with me.
And then there's the like the,
the knowledge that you're going to do it again.
You know,
you know you're going to do it again.
Like an alcoholic who can't put that drink down.
If you're gonna do it again,
you'd get to do it again.
I have no shame.
I want it to last longer.
I just,
I love it.
Yeah.
Everybody wants to hear that right now.
People are throwing up in their car thinking about you beating off all of your
pasty,
hairy stomach.
How dare you?
How dare you like Dandruff?
Well,
it's good that they didn't fire this dude for beating off in the forest or
whatever the fuck happened.
It doesn't seem like a bad guy.
Just see,
it's called CNN gentlemen.
We don't have to shame.
I'm just shot Maddie.
I'm just shocked.
Like you get caught with a rope around your Dick and math and you have a TV job.
Well he could have been,
he might be gay and if he's gay they might be less likely to fight a big hard.
He played the car,
he played the game.
I'm good for him.
He got,
he did,
you know,
well he's like,
this is the gay community.
We don't have children and walk out and watch out for us.
So we like to do math and stick stuff up our ass.
I paid taxes.
Chose the problem.
Yeah.
There was a curfew.
That was my only my only,
well I think that there are different rules.
There's different rules for gay dudes because they're,
they're all,
they're only,
they only have to deal with dudes.
You know,
men like clearly understand the intentions of other men.
Whereas men like barely understand how a woman works.
We understand how they work through experience,
but like as far as the actual mechanism of thinking,
the way they think,
if you are thinking your in your life and living your life and you're a man,
it's probably virtually impossible to really understand what it's like to be a
woman.
So both of us are just like trying to coexist and figure out what's okay and not
okay.
What gets you smacked?
What you know,
like that's what we're doing as men,
but gay,
gay guys don't have to do that.
Gay guys just final hold and shove it in.
Just get together to do some math together and just go fucking crazy.
There's no,
I mean they're,
the cat has food,
you know,
they haven't had the food and a little ball of water.
The cat's going to be fine.
You don't have to feed that fucking thing.
And they just bought fucked for days until they run out of carbs.
Then they have to leave the house to go get groceries.
But that's,
that's all right for them.
You know,
math,
I don't think you need the groceries,
you know?
Well,
this guy apparently didn't have groceries with them.
He did have meth.
So you've got to play.
He's just a gay dude.
Look in the party and that's how they party.
They party different.
They don't make people.
It's a different experience.
You don't have as much responsibility when you get home and you know he's not at
work.
Let them do a little math.
It's like an adrenaline rush.
A man wants his deck,
Salk.
What's the problem if someone wants to do it and he wants them to do it?
What is the real issue?
Are we crazy?
Are We puritans here?
We're going back to the old days.
What's the guy do at work?
When does it work?
Does it keep it together?
Oh fucking whatever.
Then he's a pro.
Let the guy keep it together or it gets even more impressive that way.
Now say he's your nanny.
Well that would be an issue,
but he's gay though.
Guys Party and he's bought it to Joe.
The problem is it's a baby's involved,
so it's another human being.
It's a completely different than if he was an accountant.
I'm just totally playing devil's advocate.
You are good to good devil's advocate,
but there's a responsibility of a parent to take care of a child,
so it's irresponsible.
My answer is easy,
like get the fuck out of my house man.
Don't ever fucking come back.
Don't ever come back.
Sorry.
I have a friend who was a gay nanny.
He calls him a Manny and the guy's like flamboyant,
like nipple rings and he's a black guy and he's really flamboyant but he doesn't
care.
I mean my friends very open minded and the guy's not creeping anyway.
He's just a gay guy and he's really good at working with kids.
Like he's very responsible with children.
He sees educationally does art projects with them and they're like,
he does shit with his kid.
Like if,
if he's got to watch this kid for a day,
like for five or six hours,
there's a lot of things will happen.
Like he's like,
he treats it as a professional educator almost.
So it's a very unique situation.
So I've seen guys Flamboyan as fuck.
He doesn't talk about it like they don't have conversations about it.
He goes,
he's like,
I don't want to know.
But the guys out fucking all the time out there,
just slinging dicks in the club and then taking care of little kids all day for
him.
It seems to work.
I mean,
I haven't experienced this gentleman in person.
I don't know what his personality is like whether or not I would trust him with
my kids.
God bless them,
but my friend has no problem with it.
He,
he enjoys the,
the exchange,
but he lives in San Francisco.
This kid's going to be open minded.
Yeah.
My,
my buddy,
my buddy lives in San Francisco,
which is a completely different environment,
period.
You know,
so many gay people are up there.
They're undeniable.
You can't be a hater of gays.
Have to fucking people are going to run into her gay shit.
Hollywood though.
We're in the entertainment business,
man.
It's pretty good.
If you got a hatred for games,
you're not going to get far.
Yeah.
It's not a good spot.
But you know what?
I've been accused of having a hatred for gangs because I make fun of them,
but everybody gets it.
You're all gonna get it.
Anybody who is funny,
you do something funny,
you get it.
One,
two,
you're going to get it.
It's just a joke.
I'm going to get it for myself too.
I'll get it all over me.
You know it's fucking humor.
Like make fun of yourself.
You got to,
you know that's silly.
You did get,
can't be homophobic because you have a gay joke or a joke about how you reacted
to watching Brokeback mountain.
You know that's,
I react.
That's how I reacted.
Like I was cringing.
I was tightened up,
like I barely could stay at my seat when those guys were fucking in that tent.
I bear.
I was,
as I was thinking,
oh Jesus,
like bite on his hand.
Oh my God.
Janked his pants down.
Spit on his hand.
It was that real.
See,
I never seen it.
It was intense.
But I have a similar experience because Sean Penn's a pretty good buddy of mine
and I've seen milk,
so that was tough.
I didn't see milk.
I heard it was great,
but it's one of those movies it's slipped me by and I just a great film.
But it was like tough to watch him like make out with me.
I was like,
oh,
I get it.
Can you guys just fade to black,
look into each other's eyes,
hear birds chirping.
Masi yeah,
your alarm clock goes off and oh wow.
Look at the time.
Crazy.
Hey,
it's always used to trip me out cause like I used to like that show it was six
feet under,
right?
Yeah.
And it was incredibly lot of gay characters in there.
A lot of good action.
But it would always bother me because I could,
it felt like a hot chicken and dude on the show we're going to go at it.
It'd be just a little thing,
but if the two dudes went at it,
it would be a much more long
like hang around on it of,
and you know,
that's all
part.
But it's so true.
So true.
That's so true.
It would be what the check they little making out a little bit.
Hair pulling any like,
then it would pan away to the window in it.
With the gay guys,
it's like you got like two and a half minutes and like that grunting making out
and then you know,
fade too.
Like,
and the last thing in the studio has to show that they're progressive buy by
showing you a lot of,
like [inaudible] was trying to show they're progressive,
we're progressive,
we're going to show you some gay sacks,
hey,
whatever.
And whoever was in charge of that show was more than likely there's a couple of
them that are gay and they'd be like,
we're fucking with everybody.
Right?
Well they're making the movement that they want to see and making the movie that
they want to see and the,
and that's their expression.
That's what art is all about.
Right.
You know?
But it's just saying,
let's do that,
let's treat it like we treat politics equal time,
you know what I mean?
Equal time.
That's all I'm saying.
But then try to balance it out like,
like affirmative action,
you know?
It's like they feel like gates have been held down from me all in one show.
You can't do it.
You can't affirmative back over.
Actually all I want to try to balance it back out again.
Let things get a little gay for awhile,
for a minute.
Maybe that's what's going on with overpopulation,
which didn't meet in it more
gay people.
Just let them slam each other.
Let's get a cat man.
You don't need a kid.
Jesus.
Nice.
How many people are on the four oh five so love each other.
That's respect to people that are here to the four oh five is moving well no
more.
No more babies.
Did you come to a,
to Los Angeles?
Um,
originally I was,
I was too young to even remember.
My father was a construction worker.
Came from the east coast during the whole like Palm Dale or Simi Valley first
and then Palm Dale like explosion.
Oh Wow.
So I came and then when I went back because things kind of went poorly for him a
little while and then a year or so later we came back cause he,
he stayed and like he was building,
like I said,
Simi Valley.
And so I've been here since,
you know,
seventies seventies wow.
So did,
do you remember driving on the roads back then at all?
Is it hard to remember?
No,
not really.
Not really hard to remember.
What was the traffic like?
Not Nothing compared to what it changed in,
in like late eighties you have go to Jerry's Deli and see those old pictures
that they have on the wall of like what it was like here in the 1920s and shit.
And you're like,
whoa.
That's why I love movies like Chinatown.
Like when you get to see like,
you know,
they're like houses in Chinatown in the valley was just orange groves and
fucking weird man.
It was crazy.
It shouldn't Italian Italy first,
but it's,
it's,
that's not that long ago on there.
Like what the fuck is happening?
And it's expandable.
You know why they took away all the orange groves,
right?
Cause they just stopped growing.
Well,
why?
Because know fucking
no rain,
no water.
Oh No,
we're not gonna talk about that because it will be a whole new did open up a
whole can of worms.
I forgot.
But what do you owe me?
And you will argue about it.
Engineering has to do with radiation.
Oh No,
no,
no.
It's don't worry.
You're talking about like we've had that argument already there.
We've had that argument.
It's not an argument man.
Look,
I'm no scientist and neither of you,
it's just what I've read from scientists date.
It's a,
it's a discussion about some shit that neither one of us are attached to.
No.
But the,
the um,
the area like,
like Calabasas area and shit was like ranches.
Yeah.
It's like a horse ranch isn't shit.
It's weird because when you go there now,
like the four or five all the way up to the one on one and the one on one all
the way through and see no and shit that thick.
It's thick with people fic with people every day at the amount of people that
live in the valley now.
It's just like slowly expressing itself until what does it stop?
I mean,
if it moves this foreign 50 fucking years,
what does it do in 500 years?
I mean,
is there any land left in 500 years?
Does anybody measured like how far like cities are spreading and what the fuck
happens?
And then it would just be like one of those,
what they call them,
mega cities like San Francisco to San Diego will just basically be,
that's going to suck.
It's gone.
There's no way to grow tomatoes when there's just nothing but people going to
call our herd.
That's how unfortunate way of looking at reality.
But it's true.
It's like if it,
if,
I mean,
I don't know what the,
there's,
there's studies that say that the more time passes,
the more education people receive,
the more the economy balances out,
the less people,
uh,
people,
less children.
People will have an Ashley,
they run into a problem of the population slipping.
Like,
I have heard that as well from people way fucking smarter than me on the
subject.
I loved that I couldn't be a movie that Mike Judge movie idiocracy cause it's
like the smart people are deciding to have less babies and have them at the
right time and it's like stupid people.
They just haven't fucking baby after baby after baby actually saying that.
That's like a trend in society.
Like that's what happens when cities start developing and people start getting
educated and they start getting careers.
They have started having kids later and later and then know literally you're
running into a situation where you could have like two few people like that
could happen in industrialized nations.
But then you've got places like China,
which is crazy fucked up because you have like 70% boys something not,
he liked that because everybody can only have one kid.
So everybody wants to have a boy.
So like under their boarding females,
I've heard all kinds of crazy shit they're doing if you have females.
But the fact that these poor boys are growing up in this,
no chicks like nobody thought that through.
But you're going to have more than one kid,
but it's like extreme luxury taxes on it.
And what was that what it is?
Yeah,
I'm pretty sure like you have to pay you,
you pay enough money.
You could have more than one kid,
but people don't have that kind of bread.
So they wound up only having one kid,
but that's even creepier like you have to pay to have another child and what
happens if you don't,
do you owe them?
Like what if you just have the kid?
Oh yeah,
no,
I saw a whole thing kind of on this.
I don't know if it was vice or one of those kind of like documentary ish type
things and it was like,
no,
there's a whole black market for babies and stuff in China.
It's like crazy.
Did you hear about that lady that had a baby inside of her body for like 20
years and she didn't know it and it was calcified apparently.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I just pulled it up.
Brian,
go to my Twitter.
It's on my Twitter.
I just a,
I just tweeted this,
this is the crazy.
Have you treated that?
Cause I think I would've paid attention.
There's some you do.
I'm like,
I don't care about that.
And then there's ones that I'm like,
Ooh,
that's very intriguing.
They read that.
If you go to the second one down on my Twitter woman pregnant for 46 years gives
birth to a mummy.
She gave birth to a calcified David,
one of the signs of the apocalypse or something.
Right.
It's pretty crazy,
dude.
That's that.
That's a baby that turned into like our calcium rock.
She,
uh,
was 26 years old and she's taken to the hospital and she was supposed to get us
this area in section 80.
There's 26 no,
no,
she for 46 years.
It was in her body.
So she was like 60.
No,
I was trying to do all that man.
Like you said,
46 years,
which she's 26 years old.
She looks 90.
He is a 72 at the age of 26 prior to the hospital.
She's the one on the right.
By the way,
she was pregnant for 20,
at 26.
So that was a,
that was,
that's ridiculous.
46 years ago.
So she's 72.
Oh Dude.
And she went into Labor for 48 hours with no sign of the baby.
So she needed to have a c section,
but she wouldn't do it.
So she left the hospital.
She wouldn't,
they wanted to keep the baby alive.
The only way to do it was a c section.
She said No.
So the baby died inside of her and she stayed alive and the baby never came out
of her box.
So it stayed inside of her body and calcified.
And then she's in like serious fucking pain and she,
uh,
goes to the hospital and they found out that she had been living with this
calcified baby inside of her body for 46 years.
Can you imagine going down on that?
The smell must be like a tombstone covered
dead babies and fit.
How do you not know that's in your fucking guts?
Yeah,
that's,
I mean,
it's a fetus.
So she was supposed to be,
have a baby and to think about how big a baby is born in the picture thing is
huge.
It's huge.
Yeah,
it's huge.
It's a band.
Well it's,
it's really sad.
It's really sad because the thing tried to live outside of her body.
They tried to,
it was passing through.
It couldn't get all the way through so it tried it,
tried to stay alive inside of her body and then her body just shut it down and
then just start digesting it or changing it into a calcifying yet I guess when
your body,
uh,
finds something foreign inside of it,
sometimes it'll put like little like
coded in materials that it creates I guess like naturally the naturally
occurring thing.
So it's think turned into somehow or another we can in a cocoon and it's like
this,
the antichrist out of it and on scientists listening to me describe that
probably fucking cringing right now.
And I apologize for being retarded.
Like snake poop.
It looks gross.
Red Becomes from
Brian,
shut the phone.
You just ruined the big rib for me.
Do you need to make ribs?
Do you know why?
They were only limited edition?
Because once in a while they actual costs of rib goes down and up like the stock
market and so they just buy a shitload at that time.
What does that even rib that wouldn't,
that is,
it doesn't look like it has any bones or anything.
Meat.
Yeah,
it's part of that.
It's not good for you.
It's just,
you know,
you can't have this many people and have like real old time barbecue places
would be the only place where can get some food.
It's just too many people,
you know?
If you want it,
you got to have some,
the way we have it set up,
you're going to have to have some quick food and I'm going to be able to pull
in,
get a stupid cheeseburger and drive off because I'm busy.
Or maybe that's just how they're calling the herd lot by Mcdonald's.
Big scandal when tinfoil hat that camouflage genics today
and went there the other day and they only have two now they got rid of small.
I'm like,
can I get small?
You know,
small meal and then they're like,
we only have medium and large.
Did Not small prejudice.
You all sizes out and it's just like,
well,
we only have like the big stupid extra large one now cause it's a dollar.
They're all dollar anyway,
so here.
Yeah,
Ben men won't like small.
They don't want to buy a small boy fucking small.
I'll buy a small,
a small,
I want a small one.
I mean it.
Whoa.
Geez.
By happy man,
the smarter one's buying decks.
How dairy,
cheeseburgers Dax in Seattle.
No one wants to buy a small cheeseburger.
Hendricks in Seattle.
No.
What is it?
You Ain't had to take some Seattle ever had,
don't need to eat a bag of dicks from Seattle.
A good place where there's always a line in front of it.
It's some sort of [inaudible] six I went there twice pass by.
I never went there.
I think it passed by big line both times.
It's good.
You know Dick,
it's Dick's.
No Dick for Joe.
I would do it.
I'm not scared.
I'm not scared of head.
You got to do it just so you can say you ate Dixon Seattle,
dude.
I would say I ate at Dick so I wouldn't confuse the fuck out of people taking it
to Thursday.
Nothing wrong with being gay,
but you don't have to be gay when there's no gayness.
I mean it's called [inaudible].
It's there.
Okay.
That's what you don't want to push the gay.
It doesn't bother me dude.
Or you do.
I'm like eight in my mind.
I made up my mind to,
I'm barely ate.
I'm seven.
I'm flying.
I mate,
I've got a month from like,
that's why you got that little homophobia about me saying you ate Dixon Seattle,
if you know what I mean.
If you had the dish,
don't want to confuse people.
It's all a domino rare.
It's got my favorite line.
You think people would really get confused?
Joe
got Joe kits for eating.
Dom Irrera has the best line about that.
He goes,
I wish I was gay just so I could come out of closet.
That's how much I give a fuck.
You think I really do.
I wish I was gay.
I wish I could tell people I was gay
and he's not lying when he says it.
You know,
he's a dude,
has lived a long ass life.
He just,
he gives zero fucks.
Yeah,
he's awesome.
It's so funny when he says that too.
I wish I was gay.
He's,
he's totally serious.
Totally sober.
It gives zero fucks.
Well,
I think it's almost like an intelligence test.
If you really give a fuck that someone's gay,
it's like,
I would like to see that.
Just so I know who's stupid.
You know,
like who's blaring out?
Who's,
who's angry?
who's,
who's holding up the god hates fags signs.
Like I just,
I want to know where you are.
Just like,
cause most of them are pro gay themselves and just scared of it.
You know what I mean?
Terrified inside that they're gay.
Huge number.
Huge number of hypocritical fuck heads.
I think it's like a,
like they think they're gonna throw people off.
Like he's gay.
He's got a problem with these gay,
Billy would never say that if he was actually gay.
You know what I'm telling you?
Okay,
let's talk to my cock
for whatever reason.
But it's a weird thing when you find out that people are hating on gays and then
they do gay shit.
Like the Ted Haggard thing.
I remember that that was that big case where the guy was like,
he had like a fucking,
like a sports stadium filled with people every weekend.
Like a mega church guy.
Those mega church dudes are scary.
And all those dudes that control those gigantic huge ass fucking arena is filled
with people.
If you ever watched some of those on TV,
yes sir.
Whew.
He's the guy who got caught with like,
he got the math too and like a hotel room,
like yeah.
Isn't he on like,
there's a crazy like documentary on HBO where they have like the school where
they're like preparing like youngsters for like Christian Jihad.
Like they're like,
you're talking about a different thing,
but I know what you're,
that guy was involved in it before the scandal and I think yes,
he was.
Yes,
Yeah,
you're right.
You're right.
Um,
what is the name of that?
Uh,
that documentary.
I got it on my iTunes.
The same chick who did the followed around the president's for Hbo did,
did,
did the thing,
I forget what it's called.
She love all that stuff.
Document.
I hate when I can't remember.
I'm so stupid and Y'all telling me I threw out a website here once and it of
like crashed because no doubt that definitely happens.
Yeah.
Goddammit.
Like the pump site to buy your new CD.
Who was sure who was in this movie?
Ah,
in the movie?
Yeah.
Who to,
who created it.
Do you have any idea man?
A documentary.
She's really,
she's like the daughter of somebody in Congress or something like that.
I almost want to say like Nancy Pelosi's daughter or something like that,
but I don't think that's right.
Yeah,
it might.
It's something,
it might be because I think it's something Pelosi,
Oh man,
you're killing me.
Yeah,
it's,
that's the stoner reached dude.
That's the stoner Google
right there.
In my mind,
I'm trying to remember this fucking movie.
If anybody hears this and they know what the fuck was someone screaming right
now somebody's saying,
oh,
I usually have it on my laptop,
but this is a new laptop.
I don't even have it on here.
It's,
it's,
it's one of my favorite movies about Camp Jesus camp camp.
I had to remember,
thank God,
thank God he's just one of my favorite like crazy people movies,
Jesus camps,
a brilliant movie.
And they did it scary.
Yeah.
And they did it like they just showed you what was going on.
I mean that's what they did.
They just showed you what was going on.
They didn't give you any editorial flair to it.
No narration.
They just show you what these people feel like they're doing and how they need
to raise Christians in the same way these jihadis are being raised,
you know,
I mean this woman compares suicide bombers,
and that they're starting them off young.
So we need to start our Christian warriors off cause they're right.
This is actually the swamps there at fucking Cobra.
Raisie the shit they say to these little kids and the founder of the whole thing
was that guy.
Yes he was a big part of it.
The organization.
It is,
it is.
It's just,
it doesn't get labeled as one,
you know,
I mean the Jesus,
Jesus,
cause they haven't done anything yet.
When one of those kids does something 10 years from now,
well that that camp,
that whole thing like conservative Christians were against it.
Like radio hosts who are Christian who are conservative.
They were like this is indoctrination.
Like this isn't like what you're doing is you're,
you're making radicals.
You're not educating them about God and about love and about the,
the,
you know,
what's the Bible says you guys,
you're making like soldiers for Christ.
Admittedly.
So conservative Christians were like,
you guys are going to fucking far but these idiots,
their idea was that if the jihad is do it and what they believe in is wrong,
we should do the same thing cause we're right.
And you're like Whoa,
that's some fucking logic right there.
And they're allowed to raise kids.
It's a brilliant movie.
Yeah,
check it out.
They,
so they closed down that ministry.
Good.
They closed down because of this,
because of this movement.
Because it's like,
this wasn't even something that Christians wanted.
This was just like,
like you guys gotta fucking take it down a notch.
She didn't make it.
Who was the person that made it?
Uh,
the director's name is,
uh,
it's two people.
Heidi Ewing and Rachel Grady there.
That was wrong.
I was wrong about whom?
Anytime.
Yeah.
And they're the also the producers.
It's just fucking brilliant.
They did an awesome job with it.
Yeah.
That's scared me when I saw that the first time.
All right.
Well it's,
you know,
when you,
when you realize how easy it is to shape a child's mind,
it becomes really scary because of that.
But how many,
how many likeminded people said that's a good idea and started their own little
version of that somewhere.
You know what I mean?
Sure.
I mean,
how many people are homeschooling their kid because they want the kid to be
nutty and not influenced by the,
the,
the ridiculous Dems and libs are teaching in school.
You know,
there's a lot of people out there doing that.
Less science,
not exposing their children to other ideologies because they're worried that it
might catch,
you know,
not treating your child as if it's a growing person.
Exposing them to and finding what their groove is.
No,
no,
no.
We're going to sit down in this kitchen table.
I'm going to teach you about the Lord.
All this shit about evolution's bullshit.
Okay.
There's never been a single piece of evidence points Earth being more than
10,000 years old.
That's exactly what the Bible says as well as people,
you know,
fucking learn that shit and then you get to,
Paul's were there,
they did a Gallup poll that said 50% 46% of America believes the earth is less
than 10,000 years old.
Wow.
That's real.
Wow,
that's,
that's real.
So that's like,
I don't know how long that's going to be around for.
I have a feeling that as Internet access gets to more and more places and more
people get educated,
that kind of thinking it's probably going to go away within the next 2030 years.
I really don't see how you can keep it up.
It just seems to be at a certain point in time,
we're going to invent some sort of technology that's even more pervasive than
just looking things up.
Just looking things up in a computer.
No one ever thought of that for 500 years ago.
No one ever thought that'd be possible to us.
This is every day occurrence.
I think he's going to be a next step in the evolution of technology that's gonna
allow you to access information without actually looking things up.
You gonna be able to just get it in your head,
however,
show it somehow in your head and when that happens is not going to be any room
for this shit.
You can,
was it?
Was it,
were we having the conversation about [inaudible] Kurtzweil exactly.
The curse word.
Tell them when we were talking about transcendent man and document,
just talking about how like a technology evolves exponentially rather than
linearly and how like pretty soon we're going to have nano technology and all
that whole conversation.
I interviewed him for my Scifi show.
I got to talk to him for over an hour.
It was fucking awesome.
She's crazy amazing because it's math.
Well,
he's also predicted everything he predicted the search engine way before it
existed.
He predicted the Internet before it existed.
He created voice recognition software.
I mean this,
this motherfucker's been around for a long time.
Breaking down what's happening as far as like technological trends and makes
great keyboards to you.
Does he makes me,
isn't that incredible?
I mean,
he's just like a super genius.
He's also made like a ebook software for laptops and you know,
saw him.
Uh,
he,
we advance things.
He's like invented a bunch of different shit.
It's just a constantly thinking super genius type character and picking his
brain.
It's not like picking the brain of just some average asshole who's gonna like
tie some shitty read on scientific America.
This is a guy who's actually making these discoveries.
This is a guy who's actually been involved in many technological innovations
that have really benefited people in a big leap and he's telling you about the
future and you're like,
oh,
leash call from like a fear of death too.
He's like,
really?
He doesn't want to die.
He wants to live forever.
He wants to bring his dad back.
Yeah,
he wants to bring his dad back.
How crazy is that?
The vitamins and all that like,
well,
he thinks that we're going to get to a certain point in time where you are not
going to be a a single autonomous body function thing.
You're not going to be a single body like a flesh and bone blood.
You're not going to be that.
You're going to be a combination of tissue and artificial creations,
whether it's artificial blood cells or,
and then if the guy had already him,
yeah,
you are with your heart.
It's true for folks who don't know,
Everlast had a hard situation when they put a titanium heart valve and he goes
like,
tick,
tick.
It's fucking wild man.
So you're living proof and bionic and what he's saying is that this is just one
step and that in the future you're going to have a better version of your body.
Then your body,
they're going to be able to figure out how to get your consciousness into this
super body is Wolverine Adam hard-drives skeleton bone fucking out of your
knuckles.
Yeah.
That's comments basically into a hard drive and download your consciousness into
a hard,
yeah,
drive the guy's theory.
It's basically you're going to live forever.
He gets criticized though.
We should say a lot of people say you're never going to be able to download
consciousness,
no hard drive.
They say that the human personality is so complex and based on so many different
factors like the like how many,
how much hormones when your system at a certain time,
what stress level,
you wonder how much cortisone where you getting from it.
There's a lot of shit involved about like trying to develop a human being from
scratch to an adult.
So many steps take place.
So the,
the idea that you could actually recreate that and have anything is enjoyable as
a person.
It's tough to believe.
I mean,
I guess if you could mathematically calculate how many bad times you,
you want to inject into a person's consciousness and memory and then create them
over like a gigantic,
you know,
computer process where you're like literally inventing memories,
algorithms all there to give them an adaptive technology,
you know,
that allows them to pretend to have lived a rich and wonderful life.
And then you get like this really wise old dude,
but really someone who made them in a lab and it only took an hour and they pop
open the metal top and he comes out all steamy and shit and just dropping
science on you with his fake brain.
Yeah.
But with no bad experience,
no bad experiences,
total poser.
How fun is that going to be?
Maybe it'd be amazing.
Maybe he'll be like,
fucking doctor Manhattan.
He'll be so domain,
most interesting man in the world.
But you have fucked the dose.
I never told you my story about him that Doseck he's got,
yeah.
Did you meet him at the dude?
He's like five foot one,
like short,
maybe five foot four or something like that.
He's like little dude,
his name is like something like very Jewish.
It was like something like,
yeah.
And he told me he worked at a,
at a,
at a hardware store on Lincoln in Venice.
He probably doesn't anymore because of the gang.
That's what I think where he was working when they,
when he got the gang.
But that's not even his voice too.
Oh that's hilarious.
So it,
but I don't always drink beer.
That's not his voice.
Dude.
I would drink.
Don't sick.
He's my friends stay
thirsty.
Yeah.
But those Swedish guy,
I'm not saying anything bad about him,
but he was like,
we were,
they came here to the stories.
We were playing in the playboy mansion for some,
some like charity event and like they come back to the bad seasons.
Like Yo,
the most interesting man here is in the world is here and he'd like to meet you
all.
And we were always loved those corners.
We were the clown on him.
I was like,
so we were like,
oh fuck yeah,
he's got to come back here.
I mean,
it's on Facebook.
We got pictures of it.
Wow.
But he comes in and we're all taking all these pictures and he's like,
yeah,
Hey guys,
I'm Leo Feinstein.
There's literally something like that.
I'm being,
you know,
that wasn't exactly that,
but it was so like,
oh,
someone should overdub.
And I was just like,
I was just like,
man,
if that was me,
I would be milking that to the nth degree,
man.
I would walk in and be like,
my friends at least fake it is
Marshall or the bunch of hot chicks like that and like a yacht and none of
Ferrari and drinking and mountain climbing and you go somewhere and people just
would just gravitate towards you.
That's the dude went all the cool shit in that show.
You gotta be like,
you gotta be that guy.
My friends,
it wasn't that.
It was like this little Guy [inaudible] guys,
how you doing?
Hey,
you want to have a drink?
Maybe he needs to maybe needs to change it.
Maybe it needs to bring it back and then when,
when when I saw the commercial that night,
that night I got home from the Gig and then came a commercial came on and then,
and I realized the voice was overdubbed.
I was like,
Oh man,
it doesn't seem like it.
It Joe got it.
Joe got it right there.
It seems really hilarious.
Wow.
There's a picture of him.
Oh my goodness.
Yeah.
Is that what everybody,
yeah,
it's this one little guy.
Yeah.
It seems like a nice guy though.
Nice,
Super Nice Guy.
I'm not even trying to throw him under the bus.
It was just one of the things we were so pumped and it was just like kind of one
of those let downs where you're like,
oh man,
very that personally,
if people think that when they meet me like they go short as fuck dude.
I'm like,
Oh,
this is what I am sorry.
Put them in a yoke.
Like,
Hey,
what was that clip I saw you like,
what was it?
Fear factor where you like put a guy in a yolk and like one of the contestants.
Yeah,
I thought he was gonna hit me.
He was a guy,
he had a little bit of a history of violence.
He had on one show,
he thrown his wife down and another show he had attack a counselor.
So they'd actually warned me about him before he did the show.
And uh,
his wife came back from a stunt and hit a guy and I told her,
I go,
hey,
you know,
cause they would yell at each other and screaming at each other and shit,
man,
he was a really embarrassing,
like,
you fucking idiot.
It's right there.
I go fucking get screaming at each other.
And so,
um,
one of the dudes on the show was heckling them while they were competing.
And so the woman comes back and punches the dude who's heckling her,
like punches and renting.
Somebody's really hard.
And so I go,
hey,
you can't,
I go,
just because you hit your husband doesn't mean you can go around hitting other
people.
Like you can't hit other contestants.
And then the husband gets in my face and I was like,
I saw that.
I saw that,
pushed him away.
A couple of that,
they didn't show all of it.
I pushed him away a couple of times and it kept getting closer to me and I was
like,
this guy's going to do,
this is going to escalate,
so I'm just going to grab them.
So just grabbed the back of his neck and it just felt like,
I felt like if he,
first of all,
he's going to feel this like to get ragdolled and he's not going to like that
and second,
and maybe that'll calm him down if I don't do anything to him.
So I just grabbed his head and I just held onto them a little bit that way.
Also,
if he hits me,
I'm just going to smash him.
Just draw one knee on him.
Yeah,
you're holding a hunt a guy's head.
You basically own them like you've watched Anderson Silva fight rich Franklin.
He holds his head.
When a guy that can clamp down on the back of your head and you can't get those
arms off,
that's a terrible position to be in the clear,
that's the Overeem.
They changed k one because of Alistair Overeem.
Bullock county because yeah,
bull cow.
Perfect example.
K One was like,
you know what man,
you can't be holding people's heads because in would just bum rush.
You grabbed the back of your head and it's night night,
boom,
boom.
You can't get them off you.
You can't get them off of the back of your neck.
He's huge arms.
He's got that fucking locked down grip where they just,
there's dudes who develop that fucking tightness to that hold where they slapped
that motherfucker on the back of your head.
Then they pinched down with the two forearms and you're fucked man,
and then the knees are coming.
Why can't he get it going like that and then you have seen there's a lot of
issues.
One,
okay.
First of all,
he's taken a lot of head punishment.
If you watch Alistair Overeem's k one career has his pride career,
the,
the strike force fights in Strikeforce.
Force is really,
really didn't get hit,
but he's had some brutal knockouts.
Chocolate.
Dell knocked him out.
Keratan off,
knocked him out.
Shogun knocked him out.
A lot of guys knocked out.
He finished it.
We finished him.
He got finished in kickbox abouts.
He finished.
Bought her heart too.
Yeah.
Any finished Baader too.
He's been stopped a bunch of times now.
He's been stopped twice in a row and the big foot one was fucking trauma.
That big foot one was incredible.
That combination,
there's only been one combination is good as that.
Finishing a fire with hands and that's Phil baroni versus Dave and a old school
UFC.
Have you ever seen that?
Pull that shit up.
Phil Baroni versus day Benet.
Phil Baroni is uh,
he,
you know,
he's a dude who like really underrated punching power.
Like people don't know.
He's had a lot of issues.
He's been in the game a long time.
It's had a lot of injuries,
had a lot of losses.
But when Phil Baroni clips you,
you got big problems because that is dynamic.
And this series of punches that he landed on Monday to finish him,
one of the best all time Kao scenes I've ever seen in my life.
Look at this combination.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
That's the slow mo show that like the full speed version.
If you can find,
that's a shitty version of it too.
That looks terrible.
It's like a Vito Belfort and see if he could find like a better version of it so
you could really see it clearly because it's so,
but,
but the big foot one was really similar,
real similar,
real close.
So it's like that's a lot of trauma man.
I think your brain needs a long time off after you get fucked up.
Like Brown just touched him on the chin with that foot and it was,
yeah.
And that was really the only time Brown,
he really hit him,
clean it up to that point.
And you know,
Allister almost finished him,
almost finished them and he went out full clip to try to finish him,
which if you do,
it puts you in a real bad position.
Gas Tank wise.
And when your gas tank's done,
when you thought you were going to kill the guy and the guy's still in front of
you and you can't move,
you can't move.
Yeah.
But announced,
start just kept moving forward,
kept moving forward.
You know,
he didn't want to back up.
He did.
He wanted to keep the pressure on that dude.
But that front kick to the face,
you gotta,
you gotta give it up to Travis Browne.
That shit was perfectly placed.
He tested it a couple times to the body to during the fight.
Yeah.
Well he's got a long ass reach.
Look at this.
Here's the Combo.
We get this bing,
bing,
bing.
It's when you get hit.
When you're doing like the speed bag off the,
off the off the off the fence,
man,
he might have hit him 10 times in three seconds.
It was incredible.
How many of those punches was he out?
You know what I mean?
Most of us had started doing this.
He was keeping them up with those punches,
with those punches.
The big foot fight.
Yeah.
Very similar.
So that kind of knockout I think takes a long time to recover from.
And obviously I'm not a neurosurgeon,
I'm just talking out of my ass.
But I would imagine that's an injury that's not,
it's not as simple as,
oh,
you got knocked out,
you come back,
now you're 100% now you've got an injured.
Like you,
you know what it's like to injure your back.
You know,
it's like the injury elbow,
that Shit's got to heal.
It doesn't feel the same.
And just because you don't feel your brain just because you don't feel all that
up there.
Like I would imagine your neural system has to fucking take a little bit of a
break and it's got to heal up from something like that.
So they give you like 90 days like before you're allowed to like when you get
Kayo they'll,
they'll have like a certain amount of days,
but how they can predict how one person's 90 days is same as that 90 days or
like you know,
oh Edson Barboza Terry,
Adam,
90 days when he wheel kicked homeboy and just watched them,
like you got nailed by a sniper shot.
That's a different kind of Keio then a,
a quick stoppage.
But they're both 90 days,
you know,
I think that's,
there's some significant injuries that happen.
So that could be a part of what happened to him too.
He's,
you're dealing with a dude has been knocked out at least eight times.
And what about confidence too,
right?
Like after,
I mean like you get high,
he's still super fucking confident,
man.
He's still attack Travis Brown.
He just ran out of gas.
And then there's also the issue of steroids.
There's an issue of hormones,
you know,
and he says that he,
he took,
he got popped and then they kept him off for a year and he said that the reason
why I did it was because he had a shoulder injury and a doctor prescribed it to
me.
He didn't know there's testosterone in it,
which is possible.
But then when he got off of it,
it showed that his testosterone was like super low.
Like when he lost a big foot,
they did a test on him and they found his testosterone was very low,
like in 190 range,
I think they said it was,
which is very low and it actually kind of dangerous.
Like you're not supposed to be a professional athlete where you're fucking level
so low.
And so what's your take on all the dudes doing the TRT?
Well,
here's the issue.
One trauma stops your body's production of testosterone.
It's been proven.
The pituitary gland apparently is very sensitive.
There's a guy named Dr. Mark Gordon who was a specialist in that.
He worked with James.
Tony's worked with a bunch of football players and a bunch of people coming back
from the war traumatic brain injury.
One of the things that happens is your body loses its ability to produce
hormones and so a lot of guys who've taken head trauma there,
their test levels,
la drop.
So then it becomes a question of,
okay,
if you need to take testosterone because your test levels are dropping because
you've taken a lot of head trauma,
at what point in time are we going to keep you away from head trauma?
Is there ever do we just allow it?
As long as you can keep supplementing with hormones,
we allow you to keep getting in there.
Even though your body is like,
look,
you've rattled our cage.
We're not producing testosterone anymore.
Well that's okay.
We're just going to get it from a needle and we're fine.
We're just gonna get right back in there.
You know?
I think as a a person who values personal freedom,
I certainly think they should be able to do that.
The question becomes though,
when they do it,
how much should they really be able to get?
I mean how much,
how,
I mean,
how do you,
how do we like really closely regulated because it looks like some people get
more than others.
Some people like their bodies are radically change and all of a sudden they look
like super athletes when they were kind of Doughy,
just a couple of fights before.
That's obviously something a little bit bigger than just,
you know,
bringing your,
your,
your levels up to a normal range.
It seems like they're hyper levels.
Yeah.
I don't know if it's the case,
but it looks like that.
I would you,
you'd obviously have to test them on daily basis to really get an accurate read
of what their levels are,
but the thing is,
unless you are randomly testing them on a regular basis,
people can cheat and there's ways that people could cheat anyway.
There's ways people,
people use fake dicks.
You know,
the people who have been like Tom Sizemore apparently tried to use a fake dick
when he was at a rehab place and ready to go to a halfway house.
God bless them,
they said that pulls out a fake hog.
He's trying to visit in a competent,
like what do you doing?
Good.
That's a fake Dick.
You crazy.
They sell them and we'd magazines.
Well,
there's a lot of people,
man,
that's the reality of their job.
You know?
And you have to,
you have to be clean.
But I think TRT is a tricky situation because it's hard know I think,
hey,
like freedom of being a human and if you need it in your life.
Yeah,
yeah.
But if I'm,
you know,
if I was a fighter,
what about matchmaking fan of the fight game?
It's tricky.
And to me it's almost as controversial or I say almost,
but it's almost as controversial as men,
transsexuals,
that men that become women and they want to compete as women because there's
already been one of those and there's one in basketball as well.
I think that's just as controversial as adding testosterone and being able to
find not,
I shouldn't say that.
It's not just as controversial,
but it's,
it's a,
you know,
it's close.
[inaudible] being the testosterone is weird.
The idea that you can just put it in your body and then go out there and fight
as if like you're so good,
like your body is producing that much testosterone,
you're that aggressive.
No.
Like as you get older,
your body starts slowing down like naturally.
So if you want to still compete and you want to still compete like,
like a young man,
that is the way to do it.
The question is how old should you be when you're allowed to do that?
Like if it's a 46 year old Randy couture,
you go,
okay,
I get it.
But he wasn't even doing it.
Right.
So,
but if it's,
if it's a a 27 year old guy,
which there have been,
there's been guys as young as 25 how old Vitola he's in his thirties like 34 or
something.
Right?
Let's find out.
That's not very old.
No it's not because I'm 31 yeah,
I know a couple of guys do it.
I know.
And the thing,
I mean it was like,
you know,
they,
they love it.
They said it may feel great and all this,
and then they have to do with a needle every day and everything once a week.
You do it once a week or you put on cream every day.
They're doing a needle every day.
They're crazy.
Maybe I'm mistaken,
but still it's like,
you know,
um,
and I was like,
all right,
won't for how long?
It was that forever.
Forever.
Yeah.
It's like crabbers not real.
That's part of the problem.
But if you want your body to work really good right now,
that's the solution.
The question to me is not testosterone replacement as like a,
a practice.
Because I feel like I would take anything that makes my body work better.
I'll take,
vitamins,
will take whatever it makes it work better.
Like they say,
got to do it forever.
I'm gonna brush my teeth forever too.
So a lot of Shit I'm gonna do forever then I'm not scared of.
Right.
You know,
your teeth will be gone someday.
I'll get some new ones.
Man.
I've seen Mike Goldberg got some new front teeth.
They're beautiful,
amazing,
lost and playing hockey.
They just bitches in place.
They put two right.
You got like a post in your mouth and they,
yeah,
I have a fake tooth up and then I got to get on it.
I'm actually due for one right now.
That's how crazy little operation there,
man.
Wait,
when you get the front teeth fake,
do you still have to do the rods like what I do or like the titanium rod.
He screwed it right into his head.
Yeah.
I think that's how they make sure that the teeth stay and when when they do that
they're apparently like super strong.
Like it's just like a regular tooth.
Like they have these incredible composite teeth now.
They're like really tough and well made.
They look exactly like your teeth.
I mean his shit looks perfect to wood.
It's amazing what some people have fucking gotten their teeth hack downs but
caps on to make it more pretty.
A lot of people that did that.
That's pretty crazy,
man.
That's pretty crazy.
Just for cosmetics,
like you're going to go with a full mouth of fake teeth.
Hi.
You look up,
you know you've got to pay for a mouth,
Teddy Roosevelt style.
You see so much in this town though.
I know so many people that got that done.
Yes.
I A friend of mine did it.
Yeah,
and the most.
That's creepy.
Yeah.
It's weird.
I don't,
yeah.
I don't know,
man.
I guess bleach your teeth.
Have you smoked cigarettes?
I need to do it,
but that testosterone thing,
I think it's,
it's a beginning brow and this is the real problem.
It's not testosterone and human growth hormone.
It's the inevitability,
the inevitability of biological engineering,
the inevitability that science,
technology all.
Then we'll combine because there's a massive market for figuring out how to make
the human body work better.
Kurzweil told me when I interviewed him that we're are a decade away from
inventing red blood cells that are artificial that will allow you to hold your
breath for four hours.
He said you'll be able to sit at the bottom of the pool for four hours.
A regular person.
You don't have to be a super athlete.
You don't have to be a monk.
You don't have to be some fucking dude lives in the mountains.
Just eating raw salmon for a year.
Practice and Catia.
No,
just one dude.
Some artificial blood cells injected into system.
Take a deep breath and you have plenty of oxygen for four hours.
It's fucking crazy.
And he said it's,
it's inevitable.
It's coming.
They're already working on it and it's
going to be awesome,
dude.
It's going to be incredible.
This is going to be no sense in working out,
go spear fishing.
But then when there's no sense in working out,
it's almost like,
are we going to be spoiled?
Is it going to be like the same thing that has fucked a lot of people when they
have so much access to entertain?
Man,
it's made kids lazy because they sit in front of the TV and vegetate the not as
creative or active as younger kids.
I mean that's the argument,
but what is it going to be like when you can just be a superhero?
Yeah,
boats are going to go out of business.
You can fly.
Let's just go to Catalina island.
There's a difference.
Could walk.
Yeah,
you're gonna be able to fucking hold your breath under water and walk across to
Catalina.
And when you,
when you,
all you have to do is get to the surface,
take a deep breath and go right the fuck back under and you're good for another
four hours.
Jesus Christ,
a little baby oxygen tank.
You could just walk on the ground in the hallway,
no problem.
But it will be a people of no fortitude.
Well,
they're also working on skin,
artificial skin.
That is the,
that they merge human DNA with spider silk.
It sounds like a God damn comic book.
It sounds like Spiderman,
but they're working on,
they're literally going to have artificial skin.
That's bullet proof.
So you're gonna have skin like on your body that's like your skin looks like
skin,
but it's,
it's a fucking bulletproof.
Like literally nothing can hurt it.
That's possible.
I mean,
it's not something I'm inventing with my imagination.
This is like something that they've,
they've,
it's a proof of concept idea that they're taking from like the laboratory and
they're starting to try to see if they could actually develop it.
If it's pliable,
you can still get choked out.
It's so true.
You just jump on their back.
Maybe that would be at the end all when people become impossible to knock out,
it'll all be about you.
Just,
you just got to get to that neck a let him and make bulletproof.
You're not choke proved dog.
Yeah.
Well there's a dude named Rafael dos Anjos and uh,
he got his jaw broke and a fight and now he said his jaw is a weapon because
he's had so many titanium.
He's got titanium plates and eight screws in his jaw and two dudes in a row have
broken their hand on his jaw.
Wow.
Cause he's like my job a weapon now.
Like it doesn't knock me apparently when you get your job fix too,
like that issue of like you're jogging and tink,
sometimes that goes away.
Not for every dude's,
but some time for some dudes you can't knock them out as easy.
Like once your jaw gets fixed,
apparently it's,
it's like stiffer or stays in place better yet it doesn't break as easy because
they've got screws and plates in it and wires and shit in it and it's harder to
get knocked out.
So this dude is like,
I mean,
what happens if someone like they just start making fake bones like wolverine
style.
Everybody has a scar from the top of their head all the way down to their ass
crack because they just fucking pulled you out of that bitch and put some
fucking good fake bones on you and now you never get hurt.
He just run around with fucking carbon fiber bones running through walls and
shit.
Kicking people with like an aluminum bat.
That'll be me.
Fight to the death care.
Well,
there'll be no competition anymore.
That's the real issue.
The real issue is like competition and sports is a big part of what like sedates
the masses.
It keeps people like tuned in to that as like a method of conquest.
So yeah,
we're going to fuck you kicked the Lakers ass tonight.
Ooh.
When meanwhile they're completely sedentary.
They're existing in this fucking maze is fake world and they're getting their
gladiator instincts out through that.
Well,
if that all goes away,
they're going to have to seek some sort of other release for this and that's
that.
That's,
that's an issue that people face and when you give people some sort of
distraction,
that's 46% are going to go right for it.
Okay?
That's what we got fix.
It couldn't fix that.
You just cut out,
cut out the number of dummies,
cull the herd.
How are you going to do it though?
You say that?
Okay.
Let me ask you this.
If ever Everlast if you were an alien from another planet,
Super Smart,
had your shit together.
Totally.
And he came to earth and you know you are.
Yes,
you can do whatever the fuck you want.
You're an alien.
You're from a thousand million years in the future.
You guys.
So I have no conscience or or your conscience.
But
if like if you came upon,
let me ask you this.
If you came upon a village and the village was run by a bunch of rabid monkeys,
there was millions of them.
They were fucking up everything,
throwing shit at people stealing candy,
Mcginn babies.
You would want to start killing monkeys,
right?
Okay,
well,
Mike is your intelligent little animals.
If something is so far advanced from us that it can get here from Alpha Centauri
and a metal ship,
who knows how what they're going to think about us.
They might look at us as like,
Oh,
this is this dangerous stage that a being gets when it's starting to transcend
from its animal instincts into this,
this new emergent consciousness,
this group consciousness that's inevitable for this species,
but right now it's crazy.
Right now it's running around fucking shooting guns at each other and smash into
each other on the highway and polluting things,
dumping shit in the ocean and pulling out all the fish and whew.
Leaving a giant garbage patch in the middle of the ocean,
going to punk rock shows.
Fuck rage against the machine.
Maybe they're like,
oh,
he's pitches aren't ready.
They're not ready.
We got to kill some of them.
How do we get to kill some of them?
Who Do you want to kill you?
All the stupid ones,
but we need them to work.
We need the robot.
Technology is not ready for Mcdonald's yet.
You know you can't have robot workers make any cheeseburgers.
So until that time,
what the fuck do you do?
If you were an alien and you had the,
you had to say,
well,
you know you're,
you're,
you're giving me like a kind hearted alien scenario.
Like I'm an alien with a conscience.
I could also be the alien that comes and looks at it like,
well there's this ant hill and it's in my garden and it's kind of serving a
purpose,
but it's getting too big.
So I just got to stomp out half.
She's fucking
made me.
They just throw an asteroid our way.
Maybe that's what fucked up the dinosaurs.
How's you going to do is change the degrees of the planet like by three and
either direction and the whole world's fucked.
Well,
all they have to do,
here's what pulls the plug,
don't it?
Just put it,
what are they,
what do they call that one or not?
Some electromagnetic pulse and it's easy.
Put the lights out.
Survival of the fittest.
Well one solar flare would do that,
right?
One gigantic solar flare would elite shut us down till we figured out how to
reboot things.
Clear hardrock and last and last and last.
Yeah,
you have some electronics already put into a container in the round.
Deep in the ground.
They don't have to be deep in the ground.
They just have to be well sealed within a metal container.
You like,
you can get an old style metal garbage can really take a fucking plastic bag.
Like put a plastic bag in it.
Like you're going to use real trash.
Put a bunch of walkie talkies and stuff with the like in there,
close the plastic bag tied up,
Bang,
put the lid back on it and take that motherfucker seal it shut somehow.
And like if you ever did have that electric,
magnetic pulse,
those things would still be good afterwards.
Bro,
are you a prepper?
No,
but I,
I'm,
I'm prepared though.
You Doomsday prepping.
You got electronics in a garbage bag anywhere.
Really?
Yeah.
So I got to have a glass house of the shit hits the fan and I got,
I got storage units full of water dog.
Do you really know?
Oh Damn Dude.
Yeah,
that's smart and practical.
You know what's freaking me out lately?
Not to freak people out.
Some crazy shit.
Look like Hurricane Sandy.
You know what I mean?
Look at anything like that and wouldn't yo when your whole block doesn't have
anything and nobody shows up for a week.
Listen,
my good friend lived for that.
My good friend Tommy Jr,
he told me that they used,
they had to drive four hours to use their cell phones.
Like your phone wouldn't work anywhere.
You had to drive like way the fuck out.
He lives in um,
in,
in Connecticut,
like right near the New York border.
And he had a drive,
you know,
fucking hours.
They said that food was nowhere.
Like within a day food was gone everywhere.
People were like going to Dunkin donuts and wait in line at Dunkin donuts just
to get something to fill your belly.
And then they're running out of food.
I mean there's like almost nothing left.
He said it was crazy and he said it happened so fast.
He was like,
he goes,
you would think this has helped Tommy junior talks.
She goes,
you would think they were prepared,
right?
You would think,
well let's see if the power goes out for a week.
We're going to need this amount of emergency foods so let's have it nearby goes,
fuck that dude.
He goes,
they weren't prepared at all.
It was every man for themselves and he goes in a really made you realize how
fucking scary things could get in like that.
He goes,
cause this wasn't shit.
it was a big storm,
but he was like talking about like thinking about all the things that have
happened throughout history,
human history that we know of that was way bigger than that and think about all
the shit that happened in the dark,
dark past of the fucking earth when we know let's put a carved and just a couple
of major events and now just just string a couple of those major events
together.
Like,
say
something even larger than Sandy.
Katrina is,
let's just say at the same time,
it's not,
it's far fetched,
but at any possible,
remember when that volcano went off and like nobody could fly for fucking,
I was stuck in Europe.
Dog Let go.
So let's say combine it with some super volcano eruption.
It's not that hard.
I'm not even talking about schemes are disasters of the end of the world.
I'm talking about motherfuckers get hungry,
they get vicious man,
and I'm gonna keep mines.
Yeah,
and we don't have our,
our,
our life is not set up organically right now.
Our life is set up to revolve around the,
the grid and until people develop as much food,
as much access to food organically as I do by getting things shipped and
carrying them from here and there.
If you are not responsible for the production and cultivation of your own food,
which most people don't have the opportunity to be,
then you're not autonomous.
And if you're,
if you're not,
if you can't support yourself and some shit hits the fan,
you got a real problem.
Because also something that,
God forbid,
I'm going to put in there where the truck stop coming into the supermarkets.
You know,
I got out.
So you asked me if from a prepper,
I guess.
Yeah.
You know,
in,
uh,
yeah,
I guess I am because I'm fucking ready dog.
Well,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna get you with Steve Rinella,
man.
I'm ready for like that.
I have a number,
I'll get to wherever,
you know,
I gotta get like through,
if there's a certain amount of time there's going to go.
They also,
I believe,
you know,
living in our society,
it's like,
even if something bad did happen,
you're only talking about at the worst.
You need to be able to hold yourself accountable for yourself for about three
months at its worst.
That's what I figured.
You know what I mean?
Unless we're talking about some nuclear disaster and then it's like,
who the fuck wants to be here anyways?
Take me out when that motherfucker happens.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
That's the thing,
right?
It's like,
how much damage do you want done to the earth before you like to this?
I don't want to be here and I don't want to be here for Cannibal days,
right?
When you'd rather be dead than CB bull cannibalizing.
People pull up on a ranch like,
Hey,
do you guys get any food?
And you'd see them fucking saw and a leg in the backyard and you're like,
oh,
Jesus.
They're eating people,
right?
That's going to happen.
I mean,
it would fucking happen without a doubt.
It would happen.
It's possible.
It's happened in the past.
The nez Perce Indians apparently were like big on cannibalism.
They were cannibalizing the fuck out of people because they lived in Montana and
shit got real cold in the winter and it's hard to find deer and it's even harder
to shoot him with a fucking bow and arrow.
So when you stumble upon some people that is living in some wooden house,
you're like,
oh yeah,
we got some food here.
It's ethos fucking people.
That was on a couple of hundred years and there's all kinds of which crafty
things that go with that to witchcraft team.
Yeah.
That's something I want to investigate.
Spiritual beliefs about eating humans and how power is it bestows upon the,
yeah,
the eaters and General Butt Naked Times.
It's not a power thing.
Sometimes it's like a,
there's a Nicholas Neba and he wrote a book called Keep Your River on your left
or on the right or whatever,
and he ate people.
He,
he practiced cannibalism with a specific culture and they did it when a relative
died and when the relative died,
there'd be this ceremony where they would all get together and pray and sing or
what,
or it was just like just morning,
some sort of morning.
I don't even know if they did anything,
but then they would consume ritually like certain parts of the family member
altogether.
Ooh,
that's dark.
I don't want to eat people and I definitely don't want to eat my grandma.
I definitely want it to be a stranger.
Well,
sometimes it's not a survival thing.
Sometimes it's not award thing.
Sometimes it's just like,
it's one of my jokes though.
Like whenever we're on planes or something and if we go down y'all,
y'all could,
y'all could eat me,
man.
It's okay.
Yeah.
I would trade my grandmother for somebody else,
you know,
have my grandmother eat,
take her daughter.
They're obviously not doing it to enjoy it,
you know?
Like it's just,
I guess somehow or another,
I think they're consuming something of the person who brings him closer to that
person or something.
Or we're just finalizing the idea in their mind that they're gone.
Religion something.
Have you ever been to a funeral with an open casket?
Yeah,
my father's,
my grandfather was telling one of her bender.
It was very strange.
It was tough.
It didn't,
it didn't seem like him.
No.
You know,
even though I know it was him,
I was like,
where is he?
He's not there.
No,
they aren't.
They aren't there.
That's the,
that's the bizarrest part.
It was like,
you know,
so strange.
It's the argument for that divine spark or that soul,
you know what I mean?
It's like,
cause there's not,
they're the same thing that the shells there.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
But it doesn't even look real.
It doesn't look like the same.
And I know he was made up a little bit and all this,
but I'm saying just there was something,
yeah,
I don't know what the flat right about it.
I don't know what that transition is,
but I have a feeling it's just not who we think it is.
I think the idea of life and death,
it's just what you're dealing with is one tiny frame in a fractal universe.
I remember only one thing from the experience.
What do you remember?
Just a voice.
What'd it say?
Suck it.
You know?
It was like a voice that was just familiar,
comfortable.
Kind of like your grandfather's voice.
But I wouldn't say it was my grandfather's voice.
But you understand what I'm saying?
Just and it,
it was just saying like,
I was in the wrong place kind of vibe.
I don't even know if it was words or just a feeling that was being conveyed to
me.
Right.
Look you're going to come back,
but it was definitely the only conscious thing I can remember from the
whatever's several minutes that I was supposedly dead.
Wow,
that's trippy dude.
You've been to the other side.
Maybe that's why you're so bluesy.
I don't know man.
I'm just saying it's like I just remember feeling like a very comfortable like
at situated ease kind of voice when you heard it and it was just like,
no,
you would kinda,
you ain't supposed to be here.
Kind of thing.
Like a lot of people have said that.
A lot of people that have gone through that said that,
but you know the fractal nature of the university,
like I don't know why it's so weird for people to think that something happens
after they die.
Like I showed up at your GRANDPA's house too early for your own surprise party.
That's how it felt.
Kind of like wow.
And your grandpa was trying to be like,
Nah,
don't,
that's,
that's the weirdest way I can put it.
I wonder if what it is is just we,
we,
we think that this life is all there is because this is what we're experiencing,
but this is just a temporary blip.
This is this one stage and an infinite number of stages and we leave this and go
into the next one and we shouldn't be scared of it.
Well,
that's the realization that I believe most people call your life flashing before
your eyes is the summation that your life was like when I was laying on the
table and they were rolling me in for that operation,
I was pretty much convinced I was dying.
I was going to die.
There was nothing the way they were panicking and the way my chest felt and I
knew I was born with this thing.
I was like,
Oh wow,
I'm checking out.
This is it.
And like the whole time,
and it was just sitting there like it wasn't,
I wasn't consumed with fear.
I mean though I was,
there was,
there was fear.
There was just like this summation of like,
that's my life that quick.
Wow.
Everything that I've ever done is been that only that long from the minute I was
born to now that's it.
Do the things and it wouldn't have mattered if I live 40 more years.
That's,
that would have been the exact same realization that your whole life is so,
so time is irrelevant.
Time is a is an illusion.
Time is something we made up like we're living in and we've slowed ourselves
down by counting seconds.
That's interesting.
See I
people always say that time is an illusion.
That's like a very popular thing to say.
I think time's totally real,
but I think it doesn't matter.
I think the thing is so big that your idea of time is such a joke.
Like your idea of time is like you measuring seconds in infinity.
That's what I was like clinging to something that's impossible to clean too
because although it is real and it can be measured is also movable,
it doesn't matter.
It's movable.
You know what I mean?
You can move time.
How can you move time in?
I mean you,
you do it all the time.
A small increments.
When you like make these realizations of like
all of a sudden you're somewhere.
You know what I mean?
Just that little small realization.
These are tiny things.
Precepts time is perception is okay.
It's not an illusion.
It's a perception.
I see what you're saying.
You know what I mean?
So it's like the,
it's all in the way you perceive it.
You could zone,
I can get on a 14 hour flight to Australia and zone out and I feel like I'm
there in an hour.
Right.
You know?
Is that time traveling and what's also you can,
you know what I mean?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You know?
I know what you're saying.
It's like you,
you are,
even though that this time is passing,
it's not passing for you.
You're going somewhere else.
So where is the as are you moving through time?
What are you doing?
During that time there was 17 hours on a count of four.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
And you just vegetated and lost it.
Took a nap,
came to the,
but you know the,
to take acid a lot.
It would happen all the time.
I'd sit there,
take acid,
and I'd watch the fucking sun go down and come up and it was seemed like the
span of 15 minutes.
I don't think that counts.
I think it's relevant.
I think it's related.
I don't think we'd survived Peer Review.
I think if you brought that to a university,
like,
look,
I figured out a time travel.
I dropped acid and I watched the sun.
He said,
bitch,
they Blake,
thank you,
Mr [inaudible].
You're,
you're closer than you think.
You really appreciate your contribution.
Yeah,
you're right.
They would say you're closer than you think because in,
in terms of infinity,
I mean you really did time travel.
If you decide to put a lot of energy on 14 hours in like God was going to end,
that shit will drag on forever.
Watched pot doesn't boil.
Exactly,
but it does.
The problem is it really does.
Doesn't it take longer?
It doesn't seem to take very much longer.
It seems too,
because you're not enjoying the experience.
I think everything is a matter of how much time around.
It's how you're using that time when you're moving it right.
And so in that sense,
like the more joy and love you have in your,
your time,
the less time feels like it's passing.
Absolutely.
So that's the key gaps to make things,
make things so they don't ever stretch out.
It's always like one big fun experience.
And so you're always time traveling.
Does that make sense?
But then how would you know what fun was if there was no painful one
early age or get a microchip and they stick it in the back of your head.
So Robert Johnson special
speaking to that.
That's a good transition to music.
We haven't done any fucking songs.
We're talking it up man.
Hours.
Two hours.
Yeah,
it's five 45 right now,
man.
You know he gives zero fucks and you know Everlast it's always a pleasure when
you come on here,
man.
It's always fun to just sit down and talk to you.
But you ought to promote though.
I got,
yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
You're here for,
you're here to have fun.
We went loud again.
I forgot we're on this thing.
And Mike who stick the lifestyle stick.
I got it.
You know,
which is kind of the Rogan audiences is,
is at least a more than a little responsible for this record existing.
So,
well listen,
I'm honored and uh,
I mean I've done acoustic stuff at radio stations and stuff,
but when I came in here and did it,
people started actually calling and booking shows for it.
So that's awesome.
And everybody said they'd buy it.
So I'm gonna hold y'all accountable.
Joe has like 500,000 followers,
so go get it.
Let's try and get everyone.
You ought to buy two of them.
Yeah,
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna put,
I'm gonna put that on Twitter.
I want to put it on Twitter.
Where can people get it?
If I put it up right now,
it's on iTunes or martyr Dash Inc com you will take you to all my stuff.
Stuff,
you know,
all my twitters and Instagram of bulls and face bookers.
Okay.
Brian,
find out or someone's,
Damien,
Brian,
find a link and a,
and tweet it to me so I could tweet it.
What are you gonna play now,
man?
MMM.
Let's do a little,
a little cover,
um,
which we're talking about some of this a little earlier,
but do you take requests?
If I know it,
can you do an American band?
No,
not today.
I've been obsessed with that song.
Well I came back.
I'll try and have it for you next time.
I'll have a very sad version of it next time
you will.
You'll crush my dreams.
You will man,
your attorney.
It's a homeless people at Junkies and shit.
Beautiful.
What are we going to do here?
Soon as yo make you feel,
smile
back giving you notes.
Pain is so big that you
working class,
working class
so fucking crazy.
You can't find them
being
working class.
They expect you
can't even function.
Working class
built
so clever
and
I'll fucking
working class.
Sadly.
New Loan,
lack of folks on the hill
working class,
working class.
You don't file
come from
no
fucking bad ass.
Holy Shit.
That's my favorite version of that song.
That was beautiful.
Somebody actually from your crew,
uh,
peoples and my peoples on my Twitter I think requested that last time.
I said that's not a bad idea too.
That's my favorite song now.
That was beautiful.
It was a John Lennon got damn.
He was a bad mother fucker.
John Lennon,
he wrote some interesting stuff,
man.
That's all.
What the Yoga Oh thing.
Now how'd that happen?
I don't know.
But this dude show me that.
What's,
what's happened?
What's your marijuana?
Yes.
Played it twice already.
We can't,
oh,
I wasn't mad.
I knew of that comedian guy now.
I was always fair to funny,
but I never heard that the Yoko Ono bit until he showed us his bill brown man.
Guys on camera.
So important to me.
Very like 10 of them.
10 of them didn't have that good that are,
that are out there that points it out like that and are honest about how they
feel about shit.
Like his,
his,
his take on John Leno.
I'm like,
you fucking crazy.
Cut.
Why you yell it out?
I'm here.
Single Chunk fucking and you can't leave me alone.
It's so funny.
So funny.
Bill Burns.
Beautiful.
He's beautiful.
So because like that is so important.
Joey Diaz has his fucking take on the candelabra movie.
The,
the,
uh,
the Liberace movie.
It is what the funniest fucking thing I've ever seen in my life.
You got to see Joey Diaz has bid on it.
It is so fun.
I've been to,
is it?
Oh No,
no,
no.
He has,
I don't think he's put it on anything.
It's so funny.
It hurts my ball.
I haven't seen it yet.
I got to check it out.
Oh,
it's beautiful.
It's brilliant.
And it's beautiful.
It really is beautiful.
And that's like,
you know,
saying that about a movie that's about a gay dude who's a gay pub who's just
given these dudes amphetamines and banging up and playing piano and making
hundreds of billions of dollars just running it.
He was a bad mother fucker.
Dude.
Liberace was a the,
but that was his game.
That's what he did.
He paid for the surgery.
He made his boyfriend get surgery.
So he looks like him.
Do you know how gangster that is?
Like he made the guy get a chin implant,
so he looks like Liberace.
Ooh,
that's so heavy.
You want to see of a free
shout.
Want to see this?
You could put on that video when Liberace winks at me cause you know for the
longest time I've played this before,
I apologize to people who have heard this podcast and they listen to everyone
that goes,
you got to pull it out.
Focus on again,
the only reason being is cause Everlast is here.
I just want you to see from a cultural standpoint how strange things must have
been in the 1950s where this was like a real thing.
There was a woman,
she's writing a letter to the Liberace fan club because she's a huge fan of
Liberace now.
And she goes crazy and swoons when Liberace winks at her.
And so there's Liberace playing piano on the TV and she's sitting there writing
her letter and swooning and look at this.
The shit was only 60 years ago.
I found a brand new eye.
No Watch.
Many weeks
are you gonna play along?
Brian,
check this.
We get this wink.
Not a weird noise.
Sounds like a computer made it though.
No,
it's just a chip.
Yeah.
Well let's just the additive in ancient fucking system on wax.
You can come back.
No,
there's no way.
Check this.
He's going to wake up again though.
I guarantee Ya.
He said
that he was like a matinee idol and you came across this.
Why?
I know because I,
well I got really obsessed with the movie
movie.
I saw the movie.
Well I didn't even see the movie.
I said Joey does talk about the movie first.
And then I,
I see him talking about it backstage like,
well he was in the green room and we were dying laughing when he was talking
about Liberace slinging a dick.
You're like hypnotizing motherfuckers going.
And it was so funny.
I had to watch the bit.
And so then he did this bit about it.
So the bit,
it's just ridiculous.
It's,
it's Matt Damon Liberace.
I mean it's,
it's a fucking,
it's an unbelievably hilarious bit.
So then I watched the movie and it was like,
Oh shit,
this is a good movie man.
Like this is an interesting story.
So young guy who fell for the chimes of an old rich gay guy and he just got
gangster with him and he's just there taking pills and he's,
he's got a pump fucking pump that keeps his dick hard.
So he's hard all the time.
You can never get satisfied.
[inaudible] was just,
he was a madman,
just a madman.
He had a thing stuck.
He'll was like a thing on his dick where you just get his dick hard anytime you
want.
So we just pumped that bitch up.
God bless him.
I got to this flag.
Oh,
it's a beautiful flick.
So then I started getting interested in Liberace and started researching all
this shit about Liberace and we'll start winking at you when I'm playing over
here.
Hey listen man,
I'm not homophobic.
I'm,
I'm interested in human beings and strange human characters.
And that was a,
an incredibly strange human character.
And the only thing that kept me from looking into him in the past was like that
weirdness about like doing a lot of research on a gay guy.
Like a really,
obviously,
why you pick,
why do you care about gay guys?
Why don't you care about gay guys?
Like he's just a human.
I want to know like what made that human.
He was like a Alpha gay piano like gay guy.
He made like $1 billion playing a fucking piano.
Who does that?
That's what I want to know.
And he was,
and he was a gangster when it came to his work ethic.
He was doing multiple shows in Vegas multiple per night,
you know?
And,
and he was a bad mother fucker.
Past performance made a guy change his face.
He used to come out with gigantic mink coats.
Look,
a thousand sables wrapped around his body playing.
We see those coats.
Oh my goodness.
He had fucking,
it just,
he was the original gangster rapper.
Nobody had like jewelry.
Nobody had more blank than Liberace.
He was the original,
the Gangsta rap.
He's that rapper.
He's the gangster rappers.
They copied Liberace
first.
Then Mr all the,
all the bboy jewelry stuff,
man.
And even probably Liberace stouts certainly comes from old Jewish ladies,
Cause owl glasses.
True big gold rope chains,
all that shit.
It was like old Jewish ladies would rock this fine jewelry back in New York and
that's like,
it was like,
it was the good shit.
It was the night shit.
So that's,
yeah man.
I mean like,
wow.
That actually makes sense.
I mean,
that's hilarious.
Dressed like Kool moe Dee though.
What about those?
Well,
those were just crazy glasses,
man.
I got to work
one of the greats though.
Oh,
without a doubt.
Dude.
I go to work is a fucking bad ass jam.
This doctor,
Kool Moe Dee was a real innovator,
you know,
out of those dudes that were around then.
The most amazing to me is Nas.
Nas is never stopped being relevant at wall Kumanti's a little bit before Nas,
but yeah.
But I love those like eighties and nineties guys.
When was right?
I was like early nineties early nineties yeah.
Hmm.
What was this?
Swimming nozzles are still young.
Like he,
Oh yes.
First record came out and he was like 1617 years old.
He doesn't age.
He looks good for his age.
He's only 39 wow.
That's amazing.
Really,
I would thought he was leaving a little younger than that,
but I was pretty young back then too,
so it makes sense when I was like 20 something he was running.
What is it about rappers that like very few of them are like Jay z that like
have this longevity and keep producing more wrapped as relevant.
Like some of them they get big and then they fall off.
Is that like record deal type shit?
Like what is that?
Pop Music's that way.
Pop Music.
Yeah,
there's a lot of fall.
Even with those like
doo-wop bands back in the day,
everyone only remembers like
carrot,
like Jay too.
They,
he started completely either he started independently,
someone his own records and then came into the record business as his own full
partner,
lollies cancers.
Like they got what's called a three 60 deal nowadays.
Like the label gets everything.
They get your merchandising,
they get your,
you know,
every rights they get pieces of your toying back.
When I sign record deals back in the day,
like I,
I'm,
I'm my own label now.
I do my own thing.
I'm completely independent.
But when we had made,
when I used to do major label deals,
I didn't have to give them anything but a record.
You know what I mean?
Right now they want you publishing,
they want it,
you're touring,
they want your merchandise and touring 10 cause nobody buys records.
You know what I mean?
And people buy singles,
nobody buys albums anymore.
So if they came along right now does the only deals that are available pretty
much,
unless you got something going on already,
like unless you already have developed yourself a scene and you're making,
if you're earning on your own level,
I'm sure you can go work yourself a deal somewhere and had a musicians.
But if you're doing that nowadays,
it's like you almost don't even want to do that.
You know almost.
It's like for every advantage there is to have that million dollar,
billion dollar machine behind you with the,
you know,
there's some,
there's,
there's disadvantages to it,
you know what I mean?
Well it seems like I can't do what are,
you can't do what you want.
I know of groups that have like a,
I know a group that the guy,
the head singer,
it's a group fits into tantrums in this head singer,
like supposedly just saved up a bunch of money and use his life savings to
spearhead his group.
He funded it himself,
they hit the road,
they played,
he hired good musicians,
you know,
shout out to James King,
uh,
like he just got good people on it and they'd just tour,
tour,
tour.
They did another album,
the song,
got a little radio,
love hearing their Internet love.
Now,
you know,
it just goes from there.
But if you're just like some,
nobody,
you know,
you're doing like pageants or something like that,
whatever.
And you want to be famous,
it's like they're going to be like,
Whoa,
what are they trying to do in the music business?
Right?
So if you try and do like star search
and may want to be rich and famous,
you're not doing,
you're not going out and grinding it out for 10 years.
You want to reach,
you're famous,
you're taking whichever route you can pass the tracker.
But that shit doesn't work right in order to get good.
It kind of had with jasmine.
My like a lot of them cats.
That's what happens though.
You know they get turned out by labels,
the labels done with them.
They're not hiding any more labels.
They stop supporting them.
Jay Z is a self supporting like entity.
If the labeled after him behind he,
he,
he is the label.
He can't be left.
Do you release all your own stuff?
You own all your lifestyle now?
I mean I didn't early on but the last few albums,
yeah I just do all my own stuff or these kind of like so beautiful and it gets a
little better every year.
You know more than your dorm.
The fans is going to tell other people there,
you know,
I'm still alive and you know,
and then I'm still making good music.
Then they can only sell a few more records and you know what I mean?
If you wink,
I have her last week said me,
maybe you should cover that.
Well you'd have to issue the girl version.
That doesn't make sense.
That's a girl song.
Maybe you could do a version where it check is talking,
singing and you're playing guitar now for the shut the fuck up.
There's no way to get away from that songs.
It was good.
You stepped away that gay and everything's wrong with it.
It's a mess.
The poor girls and he's like,
what's happening there?
It's a strange fucking video.
I'm thinking it was Judy garland too.
That's the crazy thing.
She had that look about it right?
That innocent 1950s woman look,
it's definitely like a wannabe Judy garland thing going on there and they
thought they were so sophisticated.
They were so much further ahead in the mon goals or American Indians or any
people before the 1950s that's 50 years away from the 18 hundreds bitch age of
innocence,
right?
Yeah.
And we had separate but equal is that the 1950s was only 50 years away from 1899
I mean that shit is like pioneer days,
you know.
So young asks society and coke.
Yeah,
cocaine was in cocaine,
cocaine,
cocaine in it.
Did you know that Coca Cola is still uses coca leaves and they process them to
make Coca Cola and they use the cocaine from those coca leaves for medical
cocaine.
They,
there's a company that,
that process for them.
They're like the biggest producer of medical cocaine we've had.
We've been,
we've tried to talk about when we're talking about,
I talked about the documentary,
which ones is a crazy documentary about coca cola and South America being
involved in all these like hit like sanctioned hits and fucking like guerrilla
warfare and shit down there.
What was the name of it?
Do you remember the document like the Coca Cola cases or the Coke Cola files and
here let's shut it down again.
Document documentary,
heaven.com money dude.
It's all about,
it's too much money in coke.
How are you going to pass up on that?
That's how the CIA got involved.
They're like,
come on.
It's so much money bread down there,
man.
You got to sell at someone's buying it.
Jesus Christ.
So I just started doing it.
Supply and demand.
It is right,
right.
Illmatic was 94 that's when not started.
Yeah.
So yeah,
but he has first record was like a year or two before that.
I called live at the barbecue on main sources album.
So that was like 93 I think.
Yeah,
maybe even 92.
Yeah.
He's got the most interesting lyrics.
It's got really strange lyrics.
You know,
like that one song from Stillmatic where he plays it in reverse,
you know the song like the,
the scenario plays out in reverse,
isn't it?
It's a song about being a gun.
Yeah.
What does that song,
I think it's called I'm a gun.
Oh really?
Something like,
no,
I don't think so.
Uh,
rewind.
It's called reward.
Got Yourself a gun is the sound,
but isn't the story about being,
he has a song as a story about him actually being a gun?
Hm.
I believe it.
No.
I don't know.
Maybe a nats on that.
Stillmatic I don't know.
I'm one of his other ones are,
all those records are on a hard drive now.
So it's like,
not even like an album categories,
it's just a list of not song.
So yeah,
that's this.
I mean,
how many physical cds gets sold now and how many get sold digitally?
Um,
the people still want this more than you would think.
It's pretty dope.
I love the artwork.
Life Acoustics.
Tristan Eaton did all the artwork we just ripped off in a Wes Anderson movie and
yeah,
but it's beautiful.
It's a tribute tribute.
Yeah.
No one's gonna like get confused.
I mean,
you use the same font.
I mean everyone,
it's,
but it's really cool.
I don't think anybody thinks a movie's going to be in my and my CD there.
No.
And it's a,
it's a cool name.
I love it.
So,
uh,
but next,
um,
what about jumping around says jump around on here,
man,
but we don't really have the drum.
That situation worked out here.
We can do it without drums.
I go,
no,
no.
Don't do anything you don't want to do.
Not wanting to.
I just think it would be a little bit better if we had a drum thing.
Worked out main,
do whatever you want to do.
I want to hear whatever you want to do.
Shit,
man,
I wouldn't want you telling me what Joe's to do.
I would forget how they go.
By the way.
My Twitter handle is right in the banger.
Raven.
The banger Banger banger.
D a.
Why did you,
why did they call you raven?
The Bangor or is that what you call it?
I just made it up one day.
It's just really high.
My last name is like,
you know,
some breakdown of it means like little raven.
Right.
And then the Banger,
cause like all the famous djs sounded all like Dutch and stuff.
And like,
yeah,
like I would like to yesto yeah,
they just have these crazy European names.
So I was like,
oh,
just make it sound like different ideas.
Famous djs are,
because the famous Tj like Paul Van Dyke or whatever,
you know,
like
Flash,
it says your,
your Twitter name,
you call yourself black beauty.
Yeah.
My mom want this Guy Dui.
We're all getting like a high.
And once again,
all bad stories start with that.
And he was like,
well yeah,
you're here.
It was like,
I'm gonna call your hair black beauty man.
And so why did you just say all right,
because that's what I'm called because you know,
I'm just like,
fuck it.
Fuck yeah,
let it name you.
We know that's the Brazilian way.
Brazilians,
they all give themselves like silly nicknames.
I used to do a couple where I've heard all the silly nicknames like paid to Pano
who was a famous Jujitsu guy.
It's apparently like a cartoon,
like pay Zau big foot.
I was,
I've Avatar.
Avatar.
Yeah,
cause I like a ponytail and I'm tall and lanky and shit.
That's hilarious.
They called you.
That's funny.
The tree of knowledge.
All right.
What do you want to do,
man?
It's up to you.
What does that
red bands getting down?
Don't let him stop him now.
Skew or Saudi sweet shoe sandals.
He sat that sad with Ferris mallows bay.
She stepped inside of me,
said,
don't ever lie to me.
The sound man can be holy in s watch to see
if it adds is plead the role booth upon.
I stole the sound young and I'm and fucked up and yeah,
you
won't be loved girl
for real
now.
Down by
water
while shoe.
He,
these blue.
Now Dan's of ocean
worlds.
I would have been spoken.
See Hills.
I would have been so
hot.
Sour.
It's not really been you.
Whoa
girl,
Hazel Brown.
She left the sweetest sound.
Matches love the way that she lit up.
She spoke,
she helped ease my pain.
She states
that she could say until Shit Bro.
Shit
and false.
Some ass out watched it all go.
Whoa,
whoa,
whoa.
Mr Brian Velazco on the keys.
Black beauty,
black beauty.
Give it up.
Raven door banger.
Stop doing that.
So that's a great song.
Hey,
how was off of a record called eat at Wendy's?
And,
uh,
you're,
you're putting this out and then you're going to work on a studio album right
now I been,
I've been,
it's kind of a hip hoppers thing.
It's slow going because,
um,
it's,
it's very particular project.
It's kind of weird,
but it's going to,
so the beauty of this is there could be a volume one,
volume two,
volume three.
It's easy to go in the studio and cut the acoustic versions.
It's fun too.
So yeah.
Must be nice to have like things paired down to oh yeah,
it makes traveling so easy dude.
Oh I'm sure.
Right.
Do you just show up with a guitar?
Like how do you do it?
Oh it's three.
Just the way we show up here with,
but we don't even need to bring this cause most places will have a keyboard for
us.
Ah,
that's nice.
Right.
It's normally two guitars and three guys.
Like if you are in a big band,
like a big crazy band,
like how much shit did they have?
Like let's say like if we got to go full gear,
what's a big band?
What's a band of travels big like obviously,
um,
you too.
Oh they got semi trucks cause they have at least two,
three dimensional show,
right?
Yeah.
I mean they're carrying their own lighting rigs and their own sound systems in
their own,
you know what I mean?
Come on.
Does it take to set that shit up the day?
Wow.
You know,
they say Kevin Hart has like a,
he's got an acoustic system that he has an explosive system that he has set up
for his shows.
He shows me his punchlines
explosions go off behind the technique.
How that goes.
How bad asses that.
Ooh,
that's pretty dope.
No one can copy that either.
That shits his,
that's like,
if you want to smash a watermelon with a Sledge Hammer,
too late as Gallagher,
too late.
You know,
it's not like playing the drums.
There's certain specific things that you're not allowed to repeat if you want to
get shot in the dig with like a pool ball.
Well like you know,
rock stars can do pyrotechnics and they can also,
like other rock stars could do power techniques.
But there's never been a comedian that does pyrotechnics until Kevin did it.
So now that's it.
It's only Kevin.
Even though he didn't invent pyrotechnics,
he owns it.
They literally go off on punchline and I will like suck it.
Bitch
is fucking great.
I wish I made even at like a shitty joke.
Good.
That's cheating.
Why'd the chicken cross the road?
Because as dick was too long,
boom.
You just want to see that explosion.
Yeah,
but he's funny too.
So on top of that,
I mean that must be a destruction man.
It must be destruction.
It's a brilliant idea,
but I think you've got to do something.
If you're going to do 18,000 people with comedy,
comedy is supposed to be honestly 200 people.
Word Clay never did nothing like that.
Thanks clay.
Never did.
It might have I,
you know,
we need to ask him,
did he ever have explosions?
He might've,
he had some gigantic,
if anybody did it,
clay might might've done it.
I don't think he had them on punch lines,
but I think he might've come out to them or such lines.
That kind of wild.
Yeah.
But yeah,
he was,
I think he was probably the first comedian to do those kinds of places
consistently.
I think maybe Steve Martin had done some arenas and Eddie Murphy had done some
arenas and Richard Pryor probably did some arenas,
but when dice came on the scene,
like it was all arenas.
Tours.
Yeah,
he was the first,
he was a totally different kind of comedian because he was like a musician.
Like people wanted to hear his shit.
They wanted to hear the same shit again.
Watson,
the ball bitch.
He was like,
I'll do it with him.
It was like singing along to freeway
was reminisce of like if you,
if you remember those old like Monte Python,
when they took that on the road,
all they wanted to see was the old sketches so they could like sing along to the
merely a flesh wound.
Flesh.
That's funny.
Is that what they did?
I don't,
I'm not even aware of that though.
They do famous live like DVD of him Monty python at the Hollywood bowl.
It's hilarious.
Wow.
Well that makes sense.
Yeah.
Well yeah,
I guess
I'm a lumberjack and I'm okay and the whole audience to sing in the shit.
It's like all they did was the shift from the shows.
I'm embarrassed to say I was never a money python fan.
Really?
I like that.
I didn't like it.
I just never really watched that.
I never was in a band so money by,
so in bands he just became a mic.
I thought sort of like all these bands nerdy.
I think it was a nerdy thing to be into it cause honestly like oh some kids that
play dungeons and dragons type and I got involved with them but that's how I
found money.
Python was three of them kids cause like there was a thing called the quest for
the holy grail.
That was like a movie.
It's such a great man.
Oh Man.
Money rabbits seen right away.
Right away.
Yeah.
I remember the life of Brian.
We are the knights of them.
Get us a shrubbery
and shrubbery.
Watch it now.
I need to know.
Yeah,
I need to see it.
those guys are brilliant.
Life of Brian was Brian one where the hack the guy's arm off.
That's fucking a quest for the holy grail with the black night.
Come back here.
I'm bite your balls off.
Compare the holy hand grenade.
That's actually hilarious.
Branch dudes in the castle.
I blow my nose in your general direction.
Castle anthrax.
It was all the hot naked women in it,
so that's a great movie.
You gotta just get baked one night and watched.
Okay,
I'll do it.
I will do it.
You'll,
you'll,
well,
I just watched that.
It was laughing my ass off.
It's almost like now though,
in 2013 there's too much shit to see.
Like there's so many documentaries that I have like on my,
on my cue that I need to watch somebody movies that I haven't seen yet.
It's almost embarrassing.
He's like,
you can't catch up.
It's almost like there's too much
to old shit.
I stick to everything I grew up on.
Yeah,
my wife,
my wife always asks me like,
you've seen this movie like 500 times.
How could you watch it again?
I'll be like,
cause it's fucking good.
Go over Joey Diaz,
his houses in 90% chance to outlaw Josey Wales.
We be playing that right as you come at Joe and this is the fucking scene.
He lays it down.
These are my words of life.
He goes up to the fucking Indian,
he's on a horse.
He's going,
look,
bitch.
Either we're going to fucking work this out or I'm ready to die.
What's up now?
It's a great as far as the hill,
he'll just,
he'll be,
it'll beyond like at any given time when you come over as hotel room,
if it's on TV,
he's watching it.
Outlaw Josey Wales.
I have all the people that I've ever seen.
The Ll Josie Wales,
I bet Joey d hasn't seen it more than anyone.
It's a good movie.
It's a great fucking movie.
Certain movies that you could see over and over and over and over again.
It's good for me.
It's the mechanic Charles Bronson's mechanic and hard times number.
Hard Times high times.
Charles Bronson was a cage fighter.
What?
Oh yeah,
you don't remember.
He was a 50 year old fit cage fighter and he would go from town to town.
He had this fucking shady manager.
He had a cat that he fed milk too and he was this old wirey dude.
He was 50 years old when they filmed this shit.
See if you pull up the Sierra Knuckle Charles Bronson from hard times and Yo,
when he was 50 this mother fucker was chiseled.
Okay.
This is po before testosterone replacement therapy.
This was just the way Charles bombed mentality.
He was just doing chin ups and sit ups and shit and eating red meat,
drinking milk.
Watch
this video matter way.
Most people look at like Chuck Norris is how I look at Charles Bronson.
Oh yeah.
Charles Bronson was one of the baddest dudes ever.
Look at this
old dude and he's just fucking people.
Up to
1933 America,
people were out of work.
Life was as tough as a cheap steak.
The writing of the times,
no job and no prospects.
I look past the next event.
A man had to live by his wits.
Wilma,
man,
just start now.
He might've been like on motherfucker,
dude.
Wow.
Look how young all by his fists.
Columbia pictures.
It's like the original every which way,
but loose real one.
A drifter I love every which way,
but loose,
but it can't fuck with hard times and they are fighting fisticuffs style.
Oh yeah man who spoke so
you know why and hit hard.
That's how they used to fight when they rode bare knuckle born con man.
Well that was at Queens of Mars.
Very shitty.
Right now I'll do it like this.
Who could make a fortune in a day?
I propose a toast to the best man I know and lucid.
I'm flat broke.
I need some money fast.
You don't want no trouble.
Oh Hey,
your dad's speak.
Was the hustler easy?
I mean,
no rules about that Deb,
who when they hit her,
you ever get scared when you think of,
I'm telling you,
you can basically do anything.
He just didn't know all that other shit yet.
They didn't know about leg kicks,
you know?
No one knew and normally tie back then they did.
That's because would have bought with,
yeah.
Oh love that motherfucking kind of a pool table.
Charles Bronson,
James Colver,
Jill or rather mark fairly.
That red knock out
terrible,
terrible dies.
None of that stuff about how they win and stuff like that.
Around back then is,
I love how now like you know your why I like,
you know,
I watched that show like occasionally on Onstar.
Spartacus,
yes.
And they'll like have like a hand to hand battle and all of a sudden it's like
transitions of Jujitsu rolling into armbars in a choke hold.
And it's like,
what the fuck fuck Outta here man.
Pankration and they had that sort of,
it wasn't like that back then.
It wasn't,
part of it's the way it and whatever.
Then the evolution of Jujitsu has changed so much since,
uh,
the UFC one since 1993.
But if you go back to like the old school days with Hixon Gracie,
he,
they had all the techniques right.
They just,
it wasn't,
the
level wasn't as high as it is today,
you know,
but they're,
all the techniques were there,
you know,
most of them were triangles,
arm bars,
all that shit's been around since the 30s.
But it's just so rare that anybody got like super good at it.
The way you see like a,
you know,
Marcello Garcia or something like that,
like the guys that are today or the highest level Jujitsu guys of all time.
There's still like Hixon.
Gracie is still regarded as the greatest of all time,
but he was just such a freak.
He was so much better than everybody.
He was into some weird zone where like you would talk about everybody like,
Oh,
this guy's real good,
this guy is real good.
And then there's Hixon like in,
everybody said it,
they all agreed.
There was no debate.
It was no like,
yeah,
but I think a he Machado is better at bill's,
like takes him,
that's it.
He's the best one,
dude.
That's forever Shit,
you know?
But from then on,
you know,
besides him from then on,
basically it's constantly gotten better.
So that spark is shit that's,
they didn't fight like that.
They just didn't have enough time and stay alive long enough to learn how to
fight like that.
And he died when you're 24 and a fucking store in your stomach.
You know the,
the idea that you knew how to transition to a triangle and enroll for normal
Plata and that takes side control.
Full mounds,
arm choke,
skipped to the side bitch.
You don't know how to do that.
Yeah.
Yeah,
totally.
Totally.
That didn't happen back then.
But it's funny when they used to like,
like I wonder like I used to watch deadwood but he used to bum me out when they
swelled so much cause I'm like I can't believe that they swore that much back
then cause he didn't swear that much in like the 50s and the 60s like why am I
supposed to believe this war that much in the 18 hundreds like you sure is that
real?
I don't know if that's real.
I don't think he was supposed to be proper society either though.
I'm sure it was a pimp.
I mean the most like 90% of the squares came out of the fucking pimp guy's
mouth.
That's true most of the time.
But that guy scores so much was just like,
he was awesome.
It was amazing.
It was beautiful.
It was a feat of genius.
He,
I didn't know a human being could swear as much in as,
as,
as differently as that guy did on that show and have it sound as natural.
Oh yeah.
He just wore it rolled off his tongue is if that,
there was just a,
I swear to God,
the first time I saw an interview with that guy and he'd spoken to English
fucking accident,
I was just like,
no fucking way.
Fuck Outta here.
It's hilarious when dudes,
then you hear dudes,
you know,
and they're like English,
like really?
Like,
oh,
that there's no way that guy's not American.
You know what I mean?
There are Australian,
you ever hear Jim Jefferies do that?
Jim Brett,
Jeffery's the comedian,
he's hilarious.
Oh yeah.
He's an Australian guy.
But he can do the perfect American accent like,
yeah.
Perfect.
And it's guy freaks you out when you hear him talk and then he goes American on
you.
Yeah.
All right.
We're almost done here.
So,
uh,
let,
let's end.
You want to end with one more song?
Oh,
me tell we got that.
We could do that.
Let me think.
We're going to
do here in 10 minutes.
Okay.
Yeah.
One will,
we'll lend it.
So thank you to our sponsors on it.com.
Um,
legal zoom,
use the code name,
Rogan on both of those.
It'd be so easy if it all is all the code name Brogan,
but it's not.
So that's our sponsors.
Ladies and gentlemen,
we will see you tonight at the Ice House.
It'll be uh,
Brian Redband,
Brian Cowen,
I'm finished with me.
Sorry.
Um,
Eddie F,
Sam,
Tripoli and Wa.
And that's tonight at 10:00 PM at the Ice House.
And Joey Diaz is next door doing his podcast at eight 30.
So if you get there early,
go in and watch that shit too.
And we're going to try to convince Jodie to come over and do a set with us.
And then this weekend we're in Milwaukee,
Joey and I at the Pabst theater,
but it's basically sold out.
It was only a few tickets left,
so you might get some single seats and shit like that.
And um,
and that's it.
So we'll see you guys soon.
Tomorrow night.
We got a little release party at Hotel cafe in Hollywood.
So La,
stand out,
come on out.
Beautiful.
Where's the hotel cafe?
It's like right off Hollywood.
Been between Holloway and sunset unbelief.
Awesome.
What time is that?
10 30 yeah,
I hit at 10 30 so,
but it's a small place.
Someone like 150 seats man.
So jump on it.
Bitches life acoustic out now support Everlast go out and buy this shit.
Put your money where your mouth is.
If you fucking dirty.
Beautiful freaks.
All right,
beautiful time.
Pack it up.
Pack it.
Led me beforehand and battle me.
That's a sin.
Never snack.
Old punk.
You better back up child.
Play the
act up.
Get up,
stand up.
Throw your hand up.
Got The failing.
Jump up towards the ceiling flow.
Someone talk.
Joe T,
daft punk.
The chicken in this calves at a donut shop.
Soon enough that my mom and the map again,
get down,
get down.
It's paid out.
Jim seed,
everybody jump,
jump,
jump around from town to town.
Slag jump.
Everybody jump
as Sylvia as like John Mcenroe with you to step up.
I still smack that whole birds or your mom came to jab more in the Bible.
God,
psalms and just stack son.
Once he's getting Zach got chewing gum.
None.
Come back.
Bring a shotgun.
Ooh.
Cause the death step to me.
It take your last breath.
You gone get you
the gift.
Fashion it down.
Get Out.
Show seed.
Everybody jump around.
Jump
everybody jump around.
Jump around from town.
It sounds bad.
Too bad
we jump around,
jump around.
I'm the queen.
The crap.
I rise to the top.
I never eat a big,
there's a big as cap ed to get some Nita like Donald sorts of Nigga [inaudible]
name was Sega.
Dana one now like no bitch.
You still wanting to stab a mind,
switch it up.
Bubble around you down without your hand.
Then you,
Dan from commonly gets Ya.
Come in and get ya.
Spitting down there is the outlets.
Yeah,
that came to get down.
Get down,
get out.
You'll see them jump around.
Jump,
jump,
jump around from town to town.
From bed to bed.
Slide.
Everybody jump around.
Okay.